Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 17. Unser heutiger Gast ist MH und wir reden über Börsenkapitalismus, Casinokapitalismus und das Zocken mit Aktien und Optionen und all diesen Dingen im Allgemeinen. Wir haben uns ja letztes Mal so ein bisschen mehr über das große Ganze unterhalten, nämlich über das Geld und wo es herkommt. Und das wollen wir dieses Mal ein wenig konkretisieren. Genau. Also worum geht es denn eigentlich bei diesen Aktien?
Na, letztes Mal war es so ein bisschen VWL. Jetzt ist es so ein bisschen BWL. oder? Kann man das so sagen?
Na ja, vielleicht ein bisschen, ja.
Ja, also eigentlich geht es darum, wie sich eine Firma Kapital beschaffen kann. Wenn ich eine Firma habe und die will irgendwas bauen, dann muss ich Maschinen kaufen. Und das Geld dafür muss ich irgendwoher kriegen. Ganz früher hat man eben nur eine Firma gegründet, wenn man reich war. Und das gibt es natürlich immer noch, das modell, aber es skaliert halt nicht. Das nächste modell war, dass man schulden aufgenommen hat von anderen Leuten oder von Banken. Und seit der Ostindien-Kompanie, wir haben das in der Drogensendung angesprochen, gibt es auch das modell, dass man Anteile seiner Firma verkauft und die heißen eben Aktien. Und das Problem ist halt, wenn ich einen Anteil verkaufe, dann der, der den Anteil kauft, der hat dann auch ein Mitspracherecht. Das ist so ein bisschen problematisch und deswegen hat man bei Aktien noch modelle gebaut, um das Mitspracherecht einzuschränken oder ganz wegfallen zu lassen. Das sind die Vorzugsaktien.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch ein bisschen genauer erklären, was denn eigentlich so eine Aktie ist. Na also, ich bin jetzt mal Unternehmer und ich will jetzt mal irgendwie Geld haben. Wie mache ich das denn? Also wie geht es los, wenn du ein Unternehmer mit einer Aktiengesellschaft bist?
Na damit geht es los, dass du die gründen musst, ne?
Ja, gut.
Wie unterscheidet sich denn eine Aktiengesellschaft von der GmbH?
Na ja, also der wesentliche Grund für eine Aktiengesellschaft ist ja, dass man sie irgendwann an die Börse bringen möchte, oder? Das ist vom Prinzip her ja. Also bei einer Aktiengesellschaft ist es so, dass du Anteile des Unternehmens an die Aktionäre rausgibst oder dann Aktionäre, nachdem sie die Anteile gekauft haben. Und die dann dadurch, wie du schon sagtest, das Mitspracherecht haben und dir aber auch entsprechendes Kapital zur Verfügung stellen. Und mit diesem Kapital, was sie dir gegeben haben, dann halt auch ins Risiko reingehen. Okay, also ich baue mal irgendwie Franks kleine Schnürsenkelfabrik. Dafür brauche ich irgendwie eine Schnürsenkelmaschine. Die Schnürsenkelmaschine kostet irgendwie 10.000 Euro. Ich habe nur 100 Euro, aber hey, ich weiß prima, wie man die Schnürsenkelfabrikmaschine bedient. Also gehe ich los und sage, hey, gibst du eine Schnürsenkelfabrik? Ja, die habe ich jetzt gerade gegründet und ich brauche jetzt mal Kapital, um die Maschine zu kaufen.
Franks allgemeine Schnürsenkelmaschine.
Genau, meine allgemeine schnürsenkelbedarfstundeckungs-ag. Wie komme ich denn jetzt eigentlich an diese Aktionäre? Ja, die musst du suchen. Und da du dazu wahrscheinlich selbst nicht in der Lage sein wirst, so viele Leute zu finden, die in Schnürsenkel investieren wollen, wirst du zu einer Bank gehen mit deiner, wir sagen jetzt schon mal bereits gegründeten Aktiengesellschaft. Und die bitten, die Aktionäre zu finden. Dafür kassieren die dann so ein bisschen Provision und bringen dir deine Aktionäre bei. Ja, dann bin ich noch nicht in der Börse, ne? Dann hast du erst mal nur ein paar Investoren, dann bist du noch vorwärtsig. Ja gut, ich meine, das kenne ich halt mit den Venture-Kapitalisten, die fanden früher Aktiengesellschaften mal ganz toll, bis sie dann verstanden haben, dass so eine Aktiengesellschaft in Deutschland eine bisschen andere Sache ist als eine Aktiengesellschaft irgendwo anders. seitdem stehen sie auf GABH. Ja, wir haben hier ein paar Rechte, aber... Okay, gut.
Wie äußert sich denn diese Mitspracherecht der Aktionäre in der Praxis?
In der Praxis musst du einmal im Jahr eine Hauptversammlung machen und deine Aktionäre darüber informieren, was so im abgelaufenen Geschäftsjahr passiert ist, wie die Zahlen sind. So einen schönen Geschäftsbericht. Ja, und die Aktionäre können den Vorstand wählen und absetzen. Nee, die Aktionäre können über die Hauptversammlung einen Aufsichtsrat wählen. Der Aufsichtsrat hat dann wiederum die Möglichkeit, einen Vorstand zu bestimmen. Das sind dann so Verträge, im Regelfall über fünf Jahre. Und der kann ihn absetzen, was aber vom Vorgang her recht kompliziert ist. Das heißt also im Prinzip war es eigentlich mal so gedacht, dass die Aktionäre den Unternehmer, also mich jetzt als Schnürsenkelfabrikanten, schon so ein bisschen kontrollieren können. Also dass ich nicht irgendwie mit ihrem Kapital losrenne und mir irgendwie eine goldene Nase mache, sondern halt schon tatsächlich diese Schnürsenkelmaschine kaufe, indem sie da einen Aufsichtsrat haben, der darauf aufpasst, dass mit ihrem Kapital kein Unsinn passiert. Ja, also einmal im Jahr dürfen die Aktionäre dann auch in direkten Kontakt treten, außer du erbarmst dich ihrer und telefonierst mit ihnen. Ansonsten hat die Funktion der Aufsichtsrat. Das ist dann so diese, wir erinnern uns dunkel, so zum Beispiel bei der Telekom-Hauptversammlung, da kommen dann immer die ganzen kleinen Aktionäre, die sich darüber beschweren, dass ihr Kapital irgendwo…
Und die nutzen ihr rederecht ausgiebig, verdunstig.
Deswegen wurde es ja auch eingeschränkt auf nun 10 Minuten, wenn denn der Aufsichtsrat das so möchte. Ja, okay, also wir hören schon heraus, dass die…
Das ist eher so im Nachhinein das Mitspracherecht. Diese, die kannst du im Nachhinein sagen, dass du denen nicht das Vertrauen aussprichst, dass du ihnen nicht entlastest.
Ja, das hat aber, wenn wir schon von Entlastung sprechen, das kann ja auch die Hauptversammlung machen oder muss sie einmal im Jahr machen einen Vorstand entlasten oder auch nicht? Genauso beim Aufsichtsrat, es hat nur keine rechtlichen Konsequenzen. Weil der Vorstand de facto nicht haftet. Für Scheiß, der er gemacht hat. Es sind keine rechtlichen Konsequenzen daraus vorgesehen. Das sind mehr so taktische Spielchen.
Na, was folgt denn daraus, wenn man den...
Nichts.
Oh, die Pflichten und Rechte eines Aktionärs.
Es gibt noch ganz wenige rechtliche Aspekte, wo das dann wirklich zählt, ob man einen Vorstand entlastet hat oder nicht. Aber das geht da eigentlich nur generell drum, dass man sagt, man erteilt nicht Entlastung, um auch zu demonstrieren, dass man unzufrieden ist und auch dann wieder vor Gericht sagen zu können, wenn man den dann verklagt. Ja, also guckt mal, wir haben den ja auch nicht entlastet. Aber so von der direkten Folge her ist keiner da. Okay, gut. Wir gehen mal davon aus, meine Schnürsäcke-Fabrik irgendwie mit den ersten zehn Investoren, die mir meine Bank irgendwie freundlicherweise gegen irgendwie eine geringfügige Verteiligung verschafft hat, funktioniert und ich produziere fröhliche Schnürsäcke. Und jetzt stelle ich fest, ich will aber irgendwie ausweiten und ich möchte jetzt gerne auch noch auf den, also weil ich mich mit längeren gegenständen auskenne, möchte ich jetzt auch noch Seile produzieren. Und da sagt die Bank so, naja, da kriegen wir jetzt glaube ich nicht mehr genug code zusammen, um dir die Millionen für die Seilmaschine zu beschaffen. Und dann schlägt sie mir offenbar dann irgendwann vor, lass uns doch mal an die Börse gehen, oder? Wäre das so der logische Schritt? Ja, also du gehst dann wieder zu deiner Bank, sagst du willst an die Börse gehen, und dann wirst du zu den Investmentbankern geleitet und die organisieren dir das dann. Also im großen Rahmen, im kleineren Rahmen kann man das auch unkomplizierter machen.
Du kannst auch an die Börse gehen, ohne dass du frisches Kapital brauchst gerade. Also es kommt auch vor, dass Leute an die Börse gehen, die es gar nicht müssen, weil sie halt Investoren drin haben und die möchten gerne ihre Kohle zurück haben.
Bei Venture Capital ist das ja durchaus ein übliches Vorgehen, dass halt der Cashout der Venture-Kapitalisten über die Börse funktioniert. Das heißt, sie bringen dann das Unternehmen an die Börse gebracht und dann sind ja plötzlich die Aktien handelbar. Ja gut, aber da geht es ja auch schon sehr viel über so ein IPO, weil beim Börsengang, weil du ja nicht nur neue Aktien emittieren musst, sondern du kannst ja auch noch die alten ausgeben. Und da macht man dann gerne so ein Mischverhältnis, ein bisschen neu, so sehr viel alt. Und dann steigen die Venture-Kapitalisten aus.
Wir sollen sagen, IPO heißt Initial Public Offering, das ist der Börsengang.
Ja. Und es gibt ja noch aber verschiedene Börsen. Also es gibt ja irgendwie ganz schön viele Börsen, wenn ich mich so umgucke. Und auch in Deutschland gibt es ja irgendwie mehrere kleine Börsen, große Börsen und je nachdem sortiert, was es so für Unternehmens gibt. jeder Regionalfürst möchte gerne eine Börse haben. Naja, wenn ich jetzt so nehme, mal irgendwie meine allgemeine deutsche Schnürsäckefabrik aus Berlin, wonach würde ich denn entscheiden, an welche Börse ich damit gehe? Ja, du gehst natürlich an die größte, weil du einen großen Einzug haben möchtest. Also größte heißt halt die mit dem großen handelsvolumen. Richtig, ja. Und es ist ja dann auch so, dass die meisten Unternehmen sich an allen Börsen einfach listen lassen. Also die machen da einfach keine Wahl, Auswahl. Muss ich da eine Gebühr dafür bezahlen, dass ich da gehandelt werden kann, auch wenn ich in Stuttgart oder wo auch immer? Wenn du dich einfach nur listen lässt, ohne zusätzliches, das liegt am Marktsegment schlichtweg. Wenn du zum Beispiel in den Freiverkehr reingehst, da wirst du einfach nur gelistet. Da hast du dann auch keine richtige Börsennotiz nach deutschem Recht, sondern ein Börsenlisting. Und da hast du eigentlich nur so Listingkosten. Also Listing heißt effektiv, dass ich einen Wertpapierkennzeichen bekomme und die Leute... Du kannst dann über irgendeine Börse gehandelt werden. oder auch alle. Das kostet dann halt einmalig. Und gut, da gibt es auch wieder regionale unterschiede. Frankfurt verlangt mittlerweile auch da wieder jährlich Geld. Aber so vom Prinzip her hast du da sehr geringe Kosten. Wenn du so einen richtigen Börsengang dann machst, da wird es dann halt auch richtig teuer, weil du dann wieder so eine Bankberatung brauchst. Braucht man die wirklich? oder ist das so eine irgendwie... Du brauchst halt einen, der deine Aktien vertickt. Also du bezahlst fürs Marketing? Ja, natürlich. Also so eine Bankausbildung ist heutzutage ja auch nicht mehr wie früher. Wie verwaltet man eine Bank und macht dort das Geschäft richtig, sondern das ist halt so eine Vertriebslehre. Test irgendwie alten Omis die Telekom-Aktien aus dem Auge drücken. Zum Beispiel.
Naja, wobei häufiger ist es ja wohl so, also hab ich gehört, bei den IPOs von irgendwelchen Techfirmen, dass dann die Bank hauptsächlich damit beschäftigt war, ihren Kumpels einen guten Deal zu verschaffen beim Einstieg an irgendwelche Firmen, von denen sie dachten, dass sie tatsächlich abheben.
Das ist eine Nachfragegeschichte. Was gibt es hier dann, diese Friends and Family-Programme?
Lustigerweise ist es ja so, dass bei IPOs, dass immer so gedeichselt wird, dass ein bisschen weniger auf den Markt kommt, als man vorher an Bedarf irruiert hat, damit der Kurs erstmal hochgeht.
Ja, das ist so eine...
Und da verdienen dann nämlich die ganzen Leute, die zur stunde Null schon Aktien hatten, nämlich die Friends and Family.
Ja, das ist aber eine sehr amerikanische Geschichte. Also er mit seiner Schuhfabrik wird sicherlich nicht die... oder Schnürsenkel... Schnürsenkel-Seile, Entschuldigung. Schnürsenkel-Seile, wir erweitern jetzt den vierten Namen. Die Schuhe kommen dann später. Ja, die Schuhe ist ein kritischer Marker, bleiben wir lieber draußen. Okay, aber du wirst mit dem nicht unbedingt die Nachfrage erzeugen, wie beispielsweise, wenn jetzt Facebook an die Börse geht. Von daher... Weil ich meine, gerade auf Facebook sagst, Facebook-Aktien werden ja schon außerbörslich gehandelt. In so elektronischen handelssystemen. Ja, also das sind... Du kannst theoretisch... Also in Amerika ist das mehr verbreitet als bei uns. Bei uns gibt es da nur einen Anbieter, wo da irgendwie 10, 15 Firmen gelistet sind.
Super!
Du kannst... Ja, das sind halt einfach... Da sagen dann die Aktionäre, also ich will den Kram handeln und ich suche mir einfach einen Markt. Also bei den Amis ist das etwas liberaler als bei uns. Und dann gehen die halt auf diese außerbörslichen Plattformen und bieten das einfach an. Und was ist jetzt... Also warum kann ich denn als Unternehmen nicht sagen, okay, das ist eigentlich gut genug? Ja, wenn du halt einen Firmwert von 60 milliarden haben willst, dann ist es ein bisschen schwierig, dort die Liquidität dafür zu generieren. Weil nicht so viel Geld in diesem Plattform unterwegs ist. Das sind immer sehr, sehr geringe Umsätze, über die wir da reden. Also da wird vielleicht mal, was weiß ich, für zwei, drei Millionen gehandelt. Vielleicht auch manchmal ein größerer paketdeal, wenn es dann so unter den ganz Großen läuft. Aber wenn du eine richtige Publikumsaktie sein willst, wo die ganzen Fonds rein investieren und dann natürlich auch wieder den Kurs hochtreiben, da ist es zwingend, dass du an irgendeine große Börse gehst. Wobei in Amis dann New York, New York Stock Exchange, Nasdaq, bei uns halt Frankfurt etc. Aber das heißt, dass die Funktion der Börse und also auch die Größe der Börse ist ja damit eigentlich primär Aufmerksamkeit zu generieren.
Das ist wie bei Social Networks, oder?
Ja. Und so eine Börse, die sind ja keine öffentlichen Institutionen, oder?
Das ist ein Privatwirtschaftlicher.
In Deutschland waren sie es mal und wurden dann privatisiert. Also es sind halt eigentlich Firmen, die sagen, wir sind jetzt hier Börse. Ja, naja, so einfach geht es nicht. Da gibt es einen Börsengesetz. Also du kannst nicht hergehen und einfach eine Börse gründen. Da gibt es diverse Verordnungen, wo du dann auch eine Zulassung brauchst und alles. Ich kenne die jetzt aber auch nicht im Detail, weil ich noch keine Börse gegründet habe. Und die Abstufung ist dann halt so, dass man einfach einen Makler macht, wie mit außerbörsigem handelsanschluss. Das ist so die kleinste Stufe davon. Da haben wir aber in Deutschland nur einen, weil das halt einfach nicht nachgefragt wird. Also ein Makler heißt jemand, der dazu lizenziert ist, handel zu vermitteln oder? Genau. Okay. Und es gibt ja nun irgendwie so eine Makler. Sind die an den Börsen dann? oder wie funktioniert das? Also was ist deren Funktion dabei eigentlich? Jetzt kommen wir weg vom IPO.
Ja, wir wollen mal verstehen, was so alles funktioniert.
Also ein IPO ist ja nun... Also Makler ist im endeffekt vom Ursprung her mal dafür da, da müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen analog denken, als es noch keine Systeme gab, die das alles für uns gemacht haben, waren dafür da Kauf- und verkaufsorders aufzunehmen und zusammenzubringen. Und das ist die ursprüngliche Funktion von einem Makler. Und das kann ja natürlich an der Börse genauso tun, wie wenn du ihn einfach anrufst und er die dann zusammenkloppt.
Heute macht das halt ein Computer.
Genau, der richtige börsenhandel läuft heute zwar auch teilweise immer noch über Makler, aber da kriegt man halt alles über... Das läuft halt alles online. Du gibst irgendwo deine order ein und dann fließt das dort in dieses Thema. Das heißt also, eigentlich handeln an der Börse, tun die Makler untereinander oder... Früher, in diesem analogen Zeitalter, ja, nur die Makler. Das waren dann diese Typen in diesen Westen, die da auf dem Floor rumsteigen? Ja, die dann immer so irgendwo da rumschreien und rumhampeln, was man als außenstehender nicht mal ansatzweise versteht, was die da treiben oder auch nur verstehen kann. Wie die sich da verständigen. Ich fand das cool. Ich hab das früher immer so bei den Hausaufgaben, beim Hausaufgaben machen im Fernsehen immer so laufen lassen, weil es halt irgendwie so halt... Sehr beruhigend, oder? Ja, heute ist es halt so, es gibt so was wie Xetra, das ist das größte handelssystem in Deutschland, was auch uns Ausland mittlerweile lizensiert wurde. Darüber läuft auch der meiste handel mit DAX-Werten, MDAX und dem ganzen Kram, also die großen NECs in Deutschland. Das ist nur noch elektronisch. Also ich gebe da meine orders rein, jemand anders tut es und dann wird es einfach gematcht. Also diese Makler wurden durch ein Perl-Script ersetzt? In dem Fall. leider gibt es Ausnahmen. Die Ausnahmen findest du dann an diesen ganzen Regionalbörsen primär?
Naja, lustigerweise sind die Makler ein bisschen wie die Musikindustrie. Die haben sich nicht davon aufhalten lassen, dass sie eigentlich obsolet sind, sondern die haben sich im System gehalten, obwohl sie eigentlich durch ein Perl-Script ersetzt wurden.
Und es kommt immer wieder das Lobbying, um sie am Leben zu erhalten. Aber es ist halt ein Mensch und damit ein Fehlerfaktor, um schon mal da kurz vorwegzugreifen. Bei den Regionalbörsen ist es so, dass da eigentlich immer noch ein Makler dahintersteht, wenn du ein Geschäft machst. Also sowas wie Berlin, München, was gibt es da noch? Stuttgart. Düsseldorf. Hannover gibt es, glaube ich, noch. Hängt dann wieder mit Hamburg zusammen. Da ist dann immer ein Makler, der kriegt dann auf seinem Bildschirm so einen Plop. Da ist was, mach mal. Und dann führt der halt immer noch die orders zusammen, was teilweise sehr nervig ist, weil der dann auch noch wieder selber versucht, sein Geld zu verdienen und... Wie macht er das? Also er baut bestände auf und ab und versucht dann halt anhand... Also er kauft zum Beispiel, nimmt da rein, um den Deal zusammenzuführen. 100 Euro oder 118 von irgendwas und versucht, die dann natürlich auch wieder über den Markt teurer zu verkaufen. Und dadurch, dass der weniger Kosten hat als ich, hat er natürlich immer einen Vorteil. Und da können wir jetzt kurz zu diesen hybriden Systemen übergehen, was wir jetzt seit neuestem in Frankfurt haben. Da wurde dieser parketthandel abgeschafft und ein sogenanntes Xetra-2-System eingeführt, was nix weiter heißt als das elektronische System. Mit jederzeitigen Eingriffsmöglichkeit eines Maklers. Und zu sagen ein Autopilot, wo noch einer ins Steuer greifen kann. Richtig. Und das tut er natürlich sehr gerne, weil nach dem neuen Regelwerk, was damit eingeführt wurde, er die Möglichkeit hat, also es war vorher so, dass ein Makler nie gegen seinen kunden handeln durfte. Mittlerweile hat er die Möglichkeit.
Das haben wir aus naheliegenden gründen abgeschafft.
Kurz und knapp ja. Mittlerweile hat er die Möglichkeit, ohne es anzuzeigen, also ich krieg's dann erst mit, wenn der Kurs gemacht ist, einfach seinen eigenen Deal zu machen. Und damit ist natürlich dieses System. Warum sollte man solche Leute benutzen, wenn die einen dann noch verarschen? Weil nicht alle Aktien etc. gelistet sind. Ach so. Das heißt für mich als Firma, ist es dann doch ein Nachteil, nur in solchen Systemen gelistet zu sein, wo ich dann noch so einen Makler am Hals habe. Ja gut, als größere Firma wirst du ohnehin ins Cetra-System reingehen. Als kleinere wird es ein bisschen schwierig, vor allen Dingen von den Kosten her. Ach so. Was ist teurer denn? Ja, das kostet halt immer alles. gerade von Listing her sind die aufwände sehr hoch teilweise.
Das ist natürlich der Brüller, dass die vollautomatische Version mehr kostet, als die mit den Menschen drin. Also so mal rein. Automatisierungstheoretisch ein echter Rückschritt.
Okay.
Also der Markler hat ja auch noch andere Aufgaben. Der sorgt auch dafür, dass Liquidität im Markt ist. Das können wir mal kurz erklären. Was das heißt?
Liquidität im Markt macht er insofern, als er halt...
Was ist denn überhaupt Liquidität? Vielleicht mal wieder anfangen.
Ja, also wenn er dieses Matching macht, sorgt er für Liquidität und stellt dann auch mit eigenen Aktien, die er reinnimmt oder auch wieder rausgibt, gleicht er so ein bisschen die Kurse ab. Also es hat schon irgendwo einen Sinn, wenn er noch dazwischen steht, aber... Also er macht dann halt de facto den Markt. Das ist dann der Market Maker. Ja, also wenn nur er da ist, er ohnehin, ja. Und das heißt, seine Funktion ist, dafür zu sorgen, dass wenn ich meine Aktien verkaufen will, ich die im Regelfall auch loswerde, auch wenn es eigentlich erst viel später einen Käufer dafür gibt. Ja. Also wenn ich jetzt meine 50 Aktien... Also der Unterschied zwischen einem Makler und einem Market Maker ist ja, dass der Market Maker verpflichtet ist, wenn er Taxen stellt, also eine Geld-, also eine, ich muss ja anders sagen, eine Kauf- und eine Verkaufsseite. Die stellt er und die muss er dann auch abnehmen. Also auch wenn sonst keiner im Markt ist und kein Umsatz in der Aktie ist, er muss die dann stellen und muss dafür auch gerade stehen. Aber was tut er denn in so einem Augenblick, wo alle irgendwie also nehmen an, meine, ja also mein Abenteuer mit irgendwie meinen Bergseilen hat nicht so richtig funktioniert und der Kurs meiner Firma kackt gerade ab. Und ich habe aber so einen Market Maker und irgendwie alle meine Aktionäre wollen plötzlich die Aktien verkaufen, muss er die dann alle kaufen? Ja, aber er muss die ja nicht zum bestimmten Kurs kaufen. Also was heißt das, er bietet dann halt irgendeinen richtig niedrigen Kurs an, damit er die nicht kaufen muss? Also die Situation, die gibt es quasi eigentlich nicht, dass immer nur Verkäufer da sind. Also außer, wenn gerade mal wieder so eine Bubble platzt. Nee, auch da nicht. Es gibt immer, es gibt immer, es gibt komischerweise immer Käufer. Auch wenn alle verkaufen, die sind dann halt, da geht es halt immer nur um den Preis. Also wenn ich sehe, eine Aktie stürzt ein von 100 auf, was weiß ich, einen Euro, dann kann ich mir überlegen, ob ich vielleicht für 50 Cent dann doch Aktien kaufen möchte und stelle dann halt meine order rein. Aber dann ist ja schon wieder eine kauforder da und auf die kann ja wieder gehandelt werden. Da ist dann halt nur der Kurs entsprechend weit unten.
Also es gibt ja auch die Limits an der Stelle. Normalerweise gehe ich ja nicht zur Bank und sage, gib mir 100 Aktien, sondern ich gehe hin und sage, gib mir 100 Aktien zu dem Preis. Und das ist üblich, dass man da einen Preis nimmt, der noch nicht erreicht ist gerade. Dass man also sagt, ich will die Aktien zwar haben, aber sagen wir mal zwei Euro weniger, als der Aktienwert jetzt ist. Und dann geht man davon aus, es gibt innerhalb des normalen Aktienkursverlaufes, gibt es halt Schwankungen und man möchte die halt mitnehmen, wenn sie gerade ein bisschen tiefer ist. Und wenn jetzt die Aktie abstürzt, dann triggern natürlich diese ganzen Limits, die im Markt sind gar nicht unbedingt. Also es kommt auch vor, dass jemand das einfach macht, obwohl er die Aktie gar nicht haben will. Dabei denkt sich halt, naja, also wenn die tatsächlich 10 Prozent abstürzt, dann nehme ich das mit.
Aber ich meine, es gibt ja Unternehmen, also gerade zum Beispiel so Pharma-Startups, wenn die halt zum Beispiel den FDA, die FDA-Genehmigung nicht kriegen, weil sie zu viele Nebenwirkungen haben, das wird aus dieser Aktie nie wieder was. Also die fahren halt einmal ins bodenlos und dann bleiben die da halt auch. Ja, aber dafür gibt es ja dann genug day-trader, die halt diese Großschwankungen dann nochmal für Gegenbewegungen versuchen auszunutzen oder sonst noch was. oder Short-Positionen, die eingedeckt werden. Aber das muss man greifen, weil jetzt ist alles noch nicht gerade etwas weit vor.
Also wir erklären noch mal, was Liquidität ist. Genau, diese Liquidität heißt, wenn ich was verkaufen will, dass es einen Käufer gibt. Und andersrum, wenn ich was kaufen will, dass es einen Verkäufer gibt. Und das ist eine der gründe, warum man als große Firma gerne an großen Börsen gelistet werden möchte, damit eben die Wahrscheinlichkeit dafür höher ist. Und für den absoluten Notfall, dass wirklich überhaupt keiner Gegenpart da ist, gibt es halt die Marketmaker. Und Liquidität ist an sich ein hohes Gut. Denn man möchte ja, wenn man sieht, ich gucke gerade die Tagesschau und da wird gesagt, was weiß ich, Steve Jobs ist tot. Dann möchte ich ja schnell meine Apple-Aktien... Was?
Steve Jobs ist tot?
Naja, aber irgendwo war es. Dann möchte ich natürlich hingehen und meine Apple-Aktien verkaufen können. Jetzt mal, wenn ich welche hätte, was natürlich nicht der Fall ist. Demetier, demetier. Aber dann würde ich natürlich die loswerden wollen. Und das wäre ja echt doof, wenn es dann keinen Käufer gibt. Und damit das immer da ist, gibt es eben die Marketmaker. Und das nennt man Liquidität, wenn ich immer meine Sachen loswerden kann oder immer was kaufen kann. Nur der Preis kann halt sehr unvorteilhaft sein. Aber es wird eigentlich nicht daran scheitern, dass ich einfach niemanden finde, der mit mir handeln will. Damit die Marketmaker nicht verarscht werden können, was natürlich immer noch vorkommen kann, gibt es so eine Regel, dass die nicht beliebig hohe order abnehmen müssen, sondern es gibt eine Beschränkung, wie viele Aktien die abnehmen müssen. Das hängt vom Preis der Aktie auch ab. Das heißt, wenn jetzt jemand kommt und möchte eine Million Aktien kaufen, es gibt kein Gegenpart, dann würde der erstmal nur eine Tranche von, sagen wir, 1000 abnehmen. Das ist das Limit, das er zugesichert hat. Und danach kann er den Preis eben entsprechend anpassen. Das heißt, man kriegt dann nicht eine Million Aktien zu dem aktuellen Preis, sondern über den Preis reguliert der Marketmaker, dass er dann nicht komplett verarscht wird. Aber es kann immer noch Fälle geben, sehr selten wohl, aber es kann immer noch Fälle geben, wo der Marketmaker vorgeführt wird. Also stellen wir uns mal vor, der Marketmaker wird jetzt gezwungen, mir eine Aktie zu verkaufen und er hat sie gar nicht. Das finde ich ja den wichtigen Aspekt, als wenn er gezwungen wird, mir was abzukaufen. Nehmen wir mal an, er wird gezwungen, mir eine Aktie zu verkaufen, er hat die gar nicht. So was passiert dann? Erkläre das nochmal.
Wenn er sie nicht hat und ihr abkaufen muss, dann...
Die erste Strategie ist erst mal, dass er ein paar Aufhalte hat, nämlich mal.
Ja, genau. Und wenn die dann abverkauft sind, beziehungsweise dann bei dir gelandet sind, dann geht er short.
Das heißt?
Also das heißt, er gibt dir diese Aktien, ohne sie selbst zu haben und leitet sie sich woanders. oder auch nicht. Wie kann das denn tun? Also ich meine, wie funktioniert das denn technisch? Im System tut das einfach. Also da steht dann halt statt einem Plus ein Minus vor der Zahl. Also wenn ich jetzt mit meinem komischen Zocking-Account irgendwie mir Aktien kaufen will, die ich nicht habe oder verkaufen will, dann muss ich da ein Kredit für aufnehmen. Muss der Market Maker auch? Theoretisch ja. Das heißt also er, was heißt theoretisch? Praktisch ja. Also er, wenn er, beziehungsweise es ist ja umgekehrt, wenn er Aktien verkauft, die er nicht hat, dann kriegt er ja Geld. Von mir. Also ich kaufe die Aktien, du verkaufst die Aktien.
Ja, ich bin hier wieder der Durst.
Du bist der Dore, genau. Du verkaufst die Apple-Aktien, die der Marketmaker nicht hat.
Moment, Moment. Also das geht jetzt doch zu weit.
Und im System steht dann halt, hast du dann halt, zumindest bei uns, wie das jetzt bei den Maklern aussieht, habe ich jetzt auch noch nicht gesehen, aber bei uns steht dann halt einfach ein höherer Kontostand und dafür halt eine Minusposition im Depot. Und das wird ja dann auch intern bei der Bank miteinander verrechnet. Also die wissen, dass wir dann so eine Shortposition haben und verrechnen das entsprechend bei sich im System. Und dann ist es beim normalen Menschen so, dass er zwei bis sieben Tage Zeit hat. Das liegt an der Bank, diese Shortposition wieder einzudecken, sprich, sich diese Aktien richtig zu kaufen. oder er geht zur Bank und sagt, findet mir mal jemanden, der mir diese Aktien leiht. Und dann zahlst du, was weiß ich, 8 Prozent im Jahr und dann kannst du dir diese Aktien von irgendjemanden leihen und dann halt ewig diesen Minusbestand haben. Also die sind dann nur virtuelles Minus, weil du hast dir die Aktien dir gerade geborgt. Du musst halt irgendwann wieder zurückkaufen. Es geht halt darum, dass man die dann zu einem niedrigeren Kurs zurückkauft, als man sie verkauft hat. Deswegen Short. Ja. Okay. Und da gab es ja durchaus so den einen oder anderen Skandal, wo irgendjemand da Positionen aufgebaut hatte, die dann am ende so ein bisschen schwierig zu decken waren. Also das er, also wie heißt der, der mit dem Visual Basics Grip der Franzose?
Ja.
Also dieser französische Trainer, der da halt irgendwie 4 milliarden oder so in... Ach, der Jérôme Courviel oder? Und so was passiert ja irgendwie immer wieder. Und man fragt sich dann so, naja, soll ich vielleicht mal auffallen, wenn da so große Zahlen im Spiele sind?
Nein, lustigerweise ist auch diese Einschränkung mit, dass man einen Kredit aufnehmen muss, neu. Also früher ging das auch einfach so. Da hab ich einfach Aktien verkauft, die ich nicht hatte. Und hab die dann halt später irgendwann gekauft und musste mir die nicht von woanders leihen. Was hast du denn dafür?
Zocking-Account.
Nein, nicht. Also jedenfalls die Regelung, dass ich mir die jetzt leihen muss, ist neu angesichts der Krise, in der wir gerade sind. Ja, das kommt immer wieder vor, wenn eine Finanzkrise ist, dass die Regierung irgendwas tun muss, damit es in der Presse so aussieht, als gäbe es da. Also sei das Problem verstanden und wird bearbeitet.
Also ich muss kein Kredit aufnehmen. Du bist ja auch ein Bankaccount. Es ist halt so, dass die Bank eine Shortgebühr verlangt, die teilweise happig sein kann oder auch nicht. Das liegt dann auch wieder an der Bank. Damit verdient, damit halt wieder jeder verdient und alle glücklich sein. Aber kann das nicht dazu führen, wenn das viele Leute mit großen Positionen tun, also großen Mengen Aktien, dass dann sozusagen die Menge der Aktien im Markt kurzzeitig zunimmt. Also sozusagen mehr Aktien unterwegs sind, als eigentlich da sind. Ja, das ist ja das Problem mit diesen ungedeckten Short-Verkäufen.
Das ist doch beim Porsche passiert.
Naja, die haben mit Optionen rumgespielt. Das war nochmal krasser. ungedeckte Shorts, das ist ja mehr so eine amerikanische Geschichte. Bei uns ist das mittlerweile ja auch wieder verboten. Ja, die verkaufen einfach Aktien, die sie nicht haben und haben dazu auch keinen Gegenpart. Also die meint ja Indie-Lite. Genau. Das heißt, die verkaufen die einfach. Die sagen, ich verkaufe dir diese Aktie für diesen Kurs. Ja, und das wird dann halt über die Börse gematcht. Aber vom Prinzip her gibt es diese Aktien in dem Moment auch gar nicht. Okay, und dann? Also ich meine, was passiert denn, wenn alles gut geht? Ja, gut, wenn alles gut geht, drücken die den Kurs und die Sache deckt sich wieder ein. Aber okay, also die Limitbeschränkungen für die Generierung kenne ich da jetzt auch nicht. Vielleicht finden wir die noch nicht. Aber wer erlaubt ihnen das denn nicht?
Da gibt es ganz witzige Regelungen.
Das ist eine ewige Diskussion seit Jahrzehnten um dieses Thema und es wird halt einfach betrieben.
Eines der Argumente ist, dass es Liquidität schafft.
Ja, das ist ja immer so.
Das ist ein furchtbares Argument.
Ach so, verstehe.
Also es gibt da ganz witzige Regelungen. Die haben wir jetzt im Detail hier auch nicht aufgeschrieben. Aber eine von denen war zum Beispiel, wenn du mehrere Short-Verkäufe machst, dass der Preis nach oben gehen muss zwischen den Verkäufen, damit du nicht den da oben um... Also das Problem ist theoretisch, nehmen wir mal an, ich will jetzt eine Firma in die Pleite treiben und dann gehe ich hin und verkaufe einfach eine Million Aktien von denen Short. So, jetzt ist das Angebot plötzlich viel höher als die Nachfrage, weil ich künstlich Aktien, die es gar nicht gibt, verkaufe. Das treibt den Preis nach unten. So, und wenn ich das hoch genug mache, dann gehe ich natürlich ein riesiges Risiko ein.
Also hoch genug, nummer als mit vielen Aktien.
Genügend vielen Aktien. Dann kann ich damit den Aktienkurs zerstören, im grunde, weil ich einfach den Preis nach unten drücke. Und das ist auch selbsterfüllend, weil wenn der Kurs unten ist, kann ich ja günstige Aktien einkaufen, um meine Short-Position zu begleichen. Also das ist ein offensichtliches Mittel, um so einen Markt zu manipulieren. Und deswegen gibt es halt die Frage, was man da regulieren kann, um das zu verhindern. Und da gibt es halt diverse Heuristiken, die alle nicht so richtig vertrauenswürdig aussehen. Aber das ist immer wieder seit Jahren in der Politik der Lieblingsfeind. Wenn an der Börse irgendwas crasht, sind es immer die Short-Seller.
Na gut, aber ich meine, diese Naked Short-Selling, ich kann mir jetzt gerade keinen Grund vorstellen, warum man dazulassen wollen würde.
Na, weil du damit auch, wenn der Markt runtergeht, Geld verdienen kannst.
Ich meine jetzt sozusagen im volkswirtschaftlichen Sinne.
Wie gesagt, es schafft Liquidität.
Also im gesellschaftlichen Sinn, voll ist das natürlich nicht. Also da sind wir dann schon im Casino-Bereich so eigentlich. Ja, aber bei uns ist es weitestgehend verboten. Ich sehe da auch keinen Sinn drin für den Markt. Das ist wirklich einfach nur Zockerei.
Das wird auch zum Hedging benutzt, also da kommen wir später zu. Es gibt auch positive Anwendungen davon, die sind allerdings nicht so ganz...
Da muss man ganz speziell Schnaps trinken, um zu verstehen, dass es positiv ist. Okay, gut. Diese Börsen sind ja nicht zusammengeschlossen. Also die sind ja nicht ein großes System, sondern die existieren ja irgendwie ein bisschen nebeneinander. Über die Makler sind sie schon so ein bisschen zusammengeschlossen. Also jede Börse ist zwar für sich, aber zumindest in Deutschland ist es so, dass die Regionalbörsen gerne mal die Kurse von der Hauptbörse einfach abschreiben. Ach so, wenn bei ihnen gerade nichts passiert ist? Und dann dort, wenn die dann einen Umsatz bekommen, dann machen die dann einfach in der Hauptbörse das Gegengeschäft und dann ist wieder alles in Ordnung. Ach so, das heißt, die Markler vertreten. Ja, das ist halt einfach so ein, weil sie selber keine Liquidität haben, um dort einen Kurs zu stellen, der irgendwie real wäre. Ist das überflüssige Menschen, oder? Ja, natürlich. Also eigentlich braucht das kein Mensch, aber es ist halt da, aus auch weitestgehend politischen gründen.
Eine Sache habe ich noch. Der Marketmaker kriegt auch Geld dafür. Und zwar von der Firma, deren Aktie er betreut. Das finde ich ein Aspekt, der nicht zu unterschätzen ist.
Ja, wir müssen uns ein bisschen aufpassen. Also wir waren jetzt wieder beim Makler eigentlich. Na gut, so genau kann man sich nicht auseinanderhalten, oder? Na ja, doch eigentlich schon. Also der eine ist halt mehr für die Liquiditätsbeschaffung. Also die gehören natürlich auch irgendwie zusammen.
Aber da sind nicht alle Marketmaker auch Makler?
Nicht alle. Also es gibt für Marketmaker spezielle Firmen, die nur das machen. Die stellen dir dann halt einfach die Liquidität. Das ist so eine Art Serviceangebot.
Spannend. Okay, und die kriegen da Geld für und zwar von der Firma, deren Aktie?
Genau. Also es ist in manchen Marktsegmenten schlichtweg vorgeschrieben, dass es einen Marketmaker geben muss. Von der Börse oder von dem? Und manchmal will man es auch einfach haben, weil man das toll findet. Warum auch immer.
Sag doch mal nach außen immer, was man da so verdient als Marketmaker.
Ja gut, das liegt an der Aktie, am Marktsegment und ein paar Variablen. Also das Niedrigste, was ich mal gehört hab, war irgendwie so um die 2000 Euro im Jahr. Und nach oben hin ist das weitestgehend offen. Also für so ein Stück Schneesinkelfabrik müsste ich so 2000 Euro investieren, damit ich einen Marketmaker habe.
Pro Jahr.
Pro Jahr. Wahrscheinlich nur, ja. Da muss ich schon ganz schön viele Schneesinkel haben.
Na wieso, du hast doch gerade Kapital reingenommen.
Ja, das hab ich doch aber an dieser Bergseilnummer versenkt. Also die sind aus dem Markt gepreist. Also die Regel ist einfach, je mehr Umsatz ist und je größer das Unternehmen ist, desto mehr bezahlst du. Okay. Aber die Börsen sind, haben wir gesagt, nicht offiziell zusammengeschlossen, sondern über die Makler. Und was heißt das? Das war ein bisschen anders gemeint. Also die schreiben voneinander ab. Und dann machen die Makler, jetzt kommen wir ja schon wieder zum nächsten Begriff, den wir nachher erklären müssen, und die Makler versuchen dann halt durch die verschiedenen Börsen natürlich auch irgendwie einen abitrage-handel zu machen. Okay, Abitrage heißt was? Beispiel, in Berlin ist der Kurs bei ein Euro, in Düsseldorf ist er bei zwei Euro. Also sagen wir es andersrum. Du kannst in Berlin für ein Euro kaufen und in Düsseldorf für zwei Euro verkaufen. Und Makler sehen das im Regelfall schneller als normale Anleger. Das heißt, der kauft dann einfach in Berlin für ein Euro und in Düsseldorf sofort für zwei Euro. Aber das kann auch ein Pearlscript viel besser.
Das macht ja auch ein Pearlscript. Aber es wird bedient von einem Spezialisten.
Von einem Spezialisten verstehe ich. Der Spezialist, der die Hand am Hebel hat.
Diese Abitrage-Geschichten sind übrigens eine der Begründungen, warum wir Spekulanten brauchen, weil das ja auch eine Spekulation.
Also es wird erstaunlich oft per Hand gemacht. Echt? Ja.
Aber es ist erschütternd eigentlich, ne?
Du fragst mich nicht, warum.
Wahrscheinlich können die alle keinen Pearl.
Ich meine, Gott, da kann man auch mitwischen wie Basic. Ja, das liegt auch sehr viel daran, was die Banken dann wieder für Schnittstellen zur Verfügung stellen, an die du dich ran kleben kannst. Und da musst du auch noch die Muße haben, dich drum zu kümmern. Und dann geht es da manchmal nur um 20, 30 Euro. Wofür dann noch relativ viel Geld wieder in die Hand nehmen musst, um die 20, 30 Euro zu machen oder wie?
Aber nur für Minuten.
Nee, es kostet halt alles Zeit und Geld. Und das lohnt sich für viele ja nicht. Wie muss man sich, lass uns mal kurz abschleifen, wie muss man sich denn diese, sozusagen die Computer hinter dieser ganzen Börsenspielerei vorstellen? Also womit arbeitest du da so mit normalen? Du siehst doch gerade, womit ich arbeite. Ich habe hier so ein ganz normales Laptop stehen von, darf ich sagen? Nee, ich darf es nicht sagen. Ganz normal Laptop stehen, völlig unaufgeregt, drei Jahre alt. Damit kann ich eigentlich alles machen. Einzige, wo er Probleme hat, ist, wenn ich mein Kursprogramm aufrufe und dann jeden Tick mehr anzeigen lasse auf größeren Börsen, wo dann irgendwie pro sekunde, was weiß ich, 20, 30 Umsätze stattfinden, dann geht der schon mal ein bisschen in die Knie.
Also die Auflösung des Bildschirms ist höher als durchschnittlich. Aber ansonsten ist das ganz normal.
Das ist richtig, ja. Okay, das heißt also dein wesentliches Arbeitsmittel sind eigentlich erst mal die ganz normale Information über die Kurse. Also ich meine jetzt nicht die Hardware ist ja uninteressant, die ist ja commodity. Mich interessiert ja eigentlich mehr, also wie muss man sich dann so einen handel vorstellen? Wir kennen ja irgendwie alle diese Web-Systeme von unseren komischen Online-Banken, die alle irgendwie stinken. Also ich habe zwei Systeme. Einmal habe ich ein Kurssystem, in dem ich mir, da habe ich eine schöne Kursliste, wo dann die Aktien drin sind, die mich interessieren. Wo ich dann die Ausführungen angezeigt bekomme und sonst noch was. Dann kann ich mir da Charts aufrufen und ja, habe da noch so ein Newsticker drin, in dem eigentlich alle News von allen deutschen Agenturen reinlaufen und ein paar Englische. Und dann habe ich noch ein zweites Programm, in dem der handel stattfindet. Das ist dann sogar sehr ähnlich aufgebaut, aber das ist nicht so gut gemacht wie hier bei dem Kostprogramm. Okay und die orders, die du da eingibst, wie wird das autorisiert? Du wirst da bestimmt den ganzen Tag die Tanz eingeben oder sowas? Nö, du kriegst eine Session Tan. Okay, also logge dich ein mit deiner Pin, dann habe ich dann so einen Tan-Generator, nennt sich das Ding, made in China.
Das gibt es inzwischen auch bei normalen Banken.
Okay. Ja, und da rufe ich dann halt eine Tan auf, gebe die ein und dann bin ich den ganzen Tag quasi in dem System drin und dann kannst du dann unten halt die orders aufgeben. Das ist eine kleine Leiste, das sind dann so vier, fünf Eingaben, die man machen muss und dann ist dieser Rallye dicht.
Also du kannst noch ein bisschen mehr sehen als normale Leute. Du kannst auch den Markt dir angucken für eine bestimmte Aktie.
Ja, also in diesem voll elektronischen Cetra-System kann man sich eine gewisse Markttiefe aufrufen, wo man so die ersten zehn Kauf- und Verkaufsgrößen sieht. Also du siehst dann halt, was es gerade an orders im Markt gibt oder gab oder zumindest zum Teil. Also alle sehe ich auch nicht.
Die, die am nächsten an dem aktuellen am letzten Kurs dran sind.
Also die ersten zehn Kaufseiten vom Kurs her. Da können immer auch mehrere orders dahinter stehen. Und daraus kannst du ersehen, wie gerade so der Flow ist oder? Nö, ich arbeite damit nicht. Ich halt das für Schwachsinn.
Ich nenne das Informations-Porn. Ist cool, wenn das jemand zeigen muss, aber hat keine intrinsischen Werte.
Also es gibt Leute, die glauben daran, was rauslesen zu können. Das Problem ist nur, dass gerade wenn du in nicht so ganz groß liquiden Aktien, selbst dort, es sind sehr viele orders drin im Markt, die einfach fake sind. Also da stellen Leute irgendwelche Kauf- und Verkaufskurse ein, die sie niemals echt meinen, einfach um den Markt zu manipulieren oder Leute daraus zu reizen, jetzt schnell zu verkaufen oder zu kaufen. Aber wie können sie die denn nicht ernst meinen, wenn sie die reingestellt haben? Ist doch eine Verpflichtung, die dann auch zu erfüllen oder nicht? Du kannst ja auch wieder rausnehmen. Ach so, wenn dann einer kommt und sagt jetzt... Also gerade bei diesen nicht voll elektronischen Systemen hast du ja immer eine sehr große Chance, weil ja da noch der Makler dazwischen steht und der immer eine Weile braucht, hast du ja eine sehr große Chance, dass die orders nicht sofort ausgeführt werden. Und es passiert dann ab und zu mal natürlich auch, dass sich da einer vertut und dann ein ungewollter order ausgeführt wird.
Das ist doch ein gutes Stichwort. Was passiert denn, wenn da Fehler passieren? Was kann man da zurückrollen? Kann man überhaupt was zurückrollen?
Also ein Makler kann, wenn er einen Fehler macht, alles zurückrollen, quasi jederzeit. Und wenn du selber einen Fehler machst, bist du der Arsch. Also du kannst gar nichts zurückrollen. Außer du machst so einen großen Fehler, dass der Daxum 100 Punkte einstürzt. Dann ist man da gnädig und macht so ein Rollback. Das heißt, dann werden die Deals, die gelaufen sind, seit deinem Fehler rückabgewickelt? Ja. Aber das ist, glaube ich, seitdem ich das mache, das sind jetzt 16 Jahre, habe ich das einmal erlebt, glaube ich, vielleicht zweimal. Okay, also es ist wirklich extrem selten. Okay. Aber lass uns mal kurz diese Geschichte zwischen den Börsen. Wie funktioniert es dann, wenn ich denn jetzt eine, also nehme an, ich meine Schnürsenkelfabrik hat irgendwie die starkte, vergebende Kurse zwischen Berlin und Stuttgart. Und in Berlin kann man es für einen Euro kaufen, in Stuttgart für zwei Euro verkaufen. Wie kommt denn die Aktie jetzt darüber? Also wie wissen denn die Börsen voneinander, dass jetzt diese Aktie in Berlin gekauft und in Stuttgart verkauft wurde? Das ist erst mal nur ein elektronischer Vorgang. Also insofern sind die natürlich schon verbunden, dass man da handeln kann. Und der reine Aktientausch, also früher hat man da ja noch wirklich Wertpapiere in Papierformen, so hübsche urkunden, im Torsor gestapelt gehabt. Mittlerweile sind das sogenannte global-urkunden, die bei einer Clearing-Stelle gelagert werden. Das ist für uns, die gehört zur deutschen Börse AG natürlich auch, die Clearstream, die ihren Sitz in Luxemburg hat. Die hat man doch schon mal, ne?
Da gab es doch schon mal so einen schönen Skandal.
Das ist die, wo der Herr Sarkozy seinen Skandal hatte. Also das ist der laden und der ist quasi an alle angebunden und verteilt dann die Aktien oder Optionsscheine oder was auch immer da gehandelt wird und hat eine Lieferzeit von zwei Tagen. Aber zwei Tage für ein elektronisches System klingt doch wie eine Ewigkeit. Das kann man bestimmt auch ausnutzen. Das wurde früher wurde durch diese verspätete Lieferung wurden Shortgeschäfte gemacht. Also da hieß es dann immer, du darfst also Shorten war früher in Deutschland komplett verboten. Und dann haben sie irgendwann die diese Lücke auszunutzen gewusst und gesagt, okay, da die Aktien, wenn du sie jetzt verkauft hast, ja noch nicht geliefert sind. Hast du sie ja noch? Hast, genau, also eigentlich ja nicht, aber du hast sie ja noch oder der Empfänger hat sie noch nicht. Und dadurch hast du jetzt zwei Tage Zeit, die Aktien zu halten und musst sie dann nach zwei Tagen aber wieder zurück kaufen. Und so hat es dann angefangen, dass in Deutschland dann peu a peu das Shorten auch in größerem Ausmaß erlaubt wurde. Okay. Also ich meine, das klingt irgendwie alles wie irgendwie eine riesige Einladung.
Zum Explore.
Da mal irgendwie mit irgendeinem Skript wahrscheinlich machen das Leute schon, oder?
Keinen, den wir kennen.
Also ich würde ja niemanden schaffen.
Nein, aber das klingt alles so, als wenn irgendwie so jemand, der sich mit Datenbankintegrität beschäftigt, würde dann nur die hände beim Kopf zusammenschlagen.
Also ist es auf alle Fälle so, dass wenn du im börsenhandel bist und darum weißt, wie die Systeme funktionieren und wo sie ihre Schwachstellen haben, dann kannst du schon sehr viel machen. Also ich kenne es halt nur aus New York, wo die die Brucker, buden massiv darin investieren, dass sie ein paar millisekunden näher am Markt sind elektronisch. Also dass sie halt einfach ihre Versuche... Da haben wir beide vorhin glaube ich drüber geredet.
Ja, also das ist so, dass früher sind die einfach näher zur Börse gezogen, physisch und haben dann Kabel gelegt und gehofft, dass die kürzer sind und dann haben sie irgendwann angefangen, einfach im Rechenzentrum Platz zu mieten.
Wo auch der Börsenrechner steht.
Wo auch der Börsenrechner steht, genau. Und daraufhin sind, also von Nestec habe ich es gehört, haben die in ihre Regulierung aufgenommen, dass die Kabel gleich lang sein müssen. Damit keiner einen Vorteil durch die Signalwege hat. Also so weit sind wir schon.
Moment, wir sind schon so weit, dass die Fasern im Rechenzentrum gleich lang sein müssen?
Nein, das ist noch Ethernet, soweit ich weiß. Ob es jetzt Faser oder Kupfer ist, weiß ich nicht.
Das ist ein Glasfaserkabel.
Ein Glasfaser? Na gut. Aber jedenfalls ja.
Du hast dann ein Nostag genommen, das Faserkabel. Und hier bitte schon, auch wenn du im selben Rack bist, musst du trotzdem 30 Meter in Kauf nehmen.
Und wenn du deinen eigenen Hub dazwischenschaltest, bist du selber schuld. So sieht es aus. Tja, aber ich glaube, das ist eher vorauseilend, als es tatsächlich Effekte gab. Ich habe ja mal so eine Erfahrung gesammelt in einer daytrading-bude in den USA. Und das war so ganz witzig, weil da hat man so ein paar Sachen einfach Zusammenhänge gesehen. Das kam mir eigentlich vor, sah es aus wie so eine LAN-Party. Da saßen so 20, 30 Leute in dunklen Zimmern, alle mit irgendwelchen großen Monitoren vor sich. Einige zockten auch irgendwie irgendeinen Warcraft, oder was damals aktuell war. Das war noch vor den Multiplayer-Sachen. Und es wurde aber am Morgen sehr geschäftig und in der letzten stunde des Tages wurde es sehr geschäftig. Und dazwischen war so, naja, Arschnarch, News lesen. Irgendwie da lief so ein nachrichtensender, CNBC und so lief. Aber ansonsten, die Leute waren alles so, sahen aus wie abgebrochene studenten. So keiner war älter als 20, Mitte 20.
Und was haben die denn getan? Also was tut man beim Day Trading?
Na, beim Day Trading geht es darum, sehr kurze Positionen zu halten. Also so nur einen Tag. Also du gehst um nichts Langfristiges, sondern du guckst dir halt den Aktienkurs genau an und versuchst aus den kurzfristigen Oszillierungen Profi zu schlagen. Und das ist halt so eine sehr, bei Gamern sagt man Twitchy. Also da sitzt halt, da muss man Reaktionen haben, wackelige Finger. Und deswegen macht das auch keiner, der älter als Mitte 20 ist. Weil da bist du einfach zu alt für den Scheiß und guckst dich so an. Also ich saß halt da als Techie und hab nix getradet und hab mir das halt erklären lassen, was die da tun. Und am Abend holten die dann den Shampoos raus und meinten, wir haben hier grad 20 Millionen gewonnen. Und da dachte ich so, kurz überlegt, ob ich das nicht vielleicht auch machen will, mich dann dagegen entschieden.
Also das kann auch anstrengender sein, als das, was die da getragen haben.
Oh, das war schon anstrengend am ende, aber halt die, also wir sollten kurz erklären, warum es am Morgen und am Abend spannend wird. Am Morgen wird es spannend, weil die Börse eben über Nacht zu ist. Und aber dieselben Werte werden dann an anderen Börsen, zum Beispiel in Tokio oder so weiter getradet. Und da kann sich der Aktienwert verändert haben. Deswegen kann man morgens möglicherweise noch irgendwelche Abitrage-Scheiße abziehen. Und abends ist es so, dass die großen Anleger noch schnell ihre ihre Bulk an und Verkäufe tätigen. Und da kann man eben auch noch mal irgendwie Sachen abziehen. Weiß ich nicht, was sie da genau gemacht haben.
Ja, also du kannst halt, also zumindest in Deutschland ist es so, dass es so eine so eine ordentliche Schlussauktion um 17.30 Uhr gibt im Xetra-System und Schlussauktion, also wenn nochmal alles wird alles verkloppt, was bei den Maklern rumliegt oder?
Nee, Auktion ist einfach eine Preiskundigung.
Das ist einfach eine Auktion, wo ein so ein ordentlicher Schlusskurs ersetzt wird. Also jetzt nochmal ordentlicher. Bei uns in Deutschland ist es halt so, das wird bei Namis dann aber auch nicht anders sein, dass diese Xetra-Auktionen, die beginnen 17.30, ändern 17.35, außer es ist irgendwas Außergewöhnliches, dann kann die auch Ewigkeiten dauern. Also gefühlt, man kann das ja immer nicht beweisen, und ich habe auch nicht vor, das wissenschaftlich zu untersuchen, ob es wirklich so ist, aber gefühlt ist es einfach so, wenn da die Großen irgendwie was abstoßen wollen, dann ziehen sie vorher nochmal so ein bisschen die Kurse hoch, damit die Aktien dann möglichst hoch in die Schlussauktion reingehen und dann kloppen die halt ihr Zeugs dann in der Schlussauktion den anderen aufs Auge. Zum Beispiel.
Genau diese kurzen veränderungen des Preises vor so einem Paket ist das, was ein Day trader aus der Nutzung versucht.
Und in der Schlussauktion ist halt auch mittlerweile so, dass ein großer Anteil des Tagesumsatzes gemacht wird. Weil die halt einfach das hat sich irgendwie so eingespielt. Kein Bock da sich die ganzen Straßen zu tun haben.
Ja doch, die haben schon Stress auch den ganzen Tag, aber da ist halt nicht viel handelsvolumen. Und dementsprechend haben die da halt Warcraft gezockt. Und als es dann in die heiße Phase überging, da haben die schon alle sehr geguckt. So ist es nicht, dass da irgendjemand rumgeslackt hätte oder so. Also das geschäftsmodell ist auch was bei uns nicht so gibt. Und zwar war das eine bude, die quasi den Bürospace vermietet hat an Leute.
Mit einer schnellen Leitung.
Genau, da gab es die Rechner, es gab die Software, es gab die schnelle Leitung und es gab jeweils ein Bloomberg Terminal für die Nachrichten. Und das konnte man sich halt mieten als Day trader und musste dann halt pro Tag genug Gewinn einfahren, um sich den Raum weiter leisten zu können. So ein typisch amerikanisches modell. Das haben hier wohl auch welche versucht, aber es lief nicht, meinst du?
Ja, es gibt, also mir sind jetzt zwei Anbieter bekannt, die das machen und noch leben. Und so um 2000 rum, mit der Internetblase und dem ganzen Kram, da gab es ein paar mehr, aber die sind irgendwie alle eingegangen. Also bei uns in Deutschland ist es auch so, dass wir sehr wenige Kapitalmarktaffine Menschen irgendwie zu haben scheinen. Das war, glaube ich, mit der Telekom-Aktie dann irgendwann vorbei.
Das haben wir ihnen abwärts so.
Aber es hat nichts so effektiv dazu beigetragen, dass die Deutschen keine Aufmerksamkeit haben. Ja, es war ja vorher schon sehr wenig. Und die Aktionärsquote liegt in Deutschland. Also bei Leuten, die direkte Aktien halten, irgendwie zurzeit so bei acht Prozent war jetzt so das Letzte, was ich gehört habe. Bei dem Telekom-Hype waren es aber auch nur zwölf, 13 Prozent. Echt? Wann wart ihr denn?
Ist das doch plus 50 Prozent?
Ja, so sagen Marketing-Leute das. Du hast da ein Talent.
Mach so ein Ding-Augen-Ring.
Du hast da ein verborgenes Talent. Das solltest du nicht ungenutzt haben. Also es ist erstaunlich, wie ich und...
Wie viel ist denn in anderen ländern so?
Also bei den Amis kriegst du da immer so mit 80, 90 Prozent um die Ohren geknallt, wenn du da mal nachfragst.
Ach gut, weil die alle Optionäre sind über ihre Firma wahrscheinlich.
Das auch noch. Aber die haben dort halt auch so eine richtige Aktionärskultur. Also das gehört halt mit zum Lebensstil, dass man sein Geld hat an der Börse vermehrt.
oder es versucht.
Also aber da bewegen sich die Zahlen auch so zwischen 70 und 90, je nachdem, wo man da nachfragt. Aber das gehört dort halt mit zum Lifestyle. Und durch Aktienoptionen, die ja zum Gehalt dort mitgehören, ist es tatsächlich so, dass die ja auch mehr oder weniger damit reingezwungen werden. Also selbst dann ist es nicht wohl. Naja, Aktienoptionen sollten wir vielleicht auch gerade noch mal erklären. Also ich kenne das halt irgendwie so aus den üblichen Start-up-Geschichten. Da funktioniert es halt so, wenn halt so ein Start-up gegründet wird, dann kannst du halt in der Regel noch keine ordentlichen Helter zahlen. Also verspricht man den ersten Angestellten, so pass auf, du kriegst halt einen Teil von den Aktien der Firma. Das heißt, wenn dann die Firma was wird oder wir in die Börse gehen mit dieser Firma, dann kriegst du halt was ab davon, von dem allgemeinen Wohlstand, der jetzt halt hier angeholft wurde. Das wird einen Preis vereinbart dann auch. Genau, es gibt dann halt irgendwie so noch die technischen Teile, zu welchem Preis kannst du diese Optionen, deswegen heißt es Optionen, einlösen. Häufig genug ist dir halt symbolisch, wenn du später dazu kommst, dann halt nicht mehr. Aber so bei den ersten Angestellten ist in der Regel halt symbolisch, was ist sich denn für ein Euro, die Aktie oder irgendwas. oder teilweise auch noch weniger.
Na gut, das kann auch nach hinten losgehen.
Ja gut, klar. Du musst es ja dann nicht ausüben. Ja, das ist dein Vorteil. Genau, also du hast ja nur die Option. Du hast ja nur dieses Mal diesen Zettel Papier in der Hand und gelegt, ich komm's dann vor, dass dir zum Beispiel die Firma diese Option wieder abkauft, weil sie halt irgendwie ihren Besitz, also ihre Besitzer konsolidieren möchte, wenn halt zum Beispiel neue 4C reinkommt. Und dann ist es so, naja, also diese ersten 50 Hippies, da die wollen wir vielleicht irgendwie nicht mehr dabei haben. Und dann kaufen sie die halt raus, indem sie denen die Optionen abkaufen. So, das passiert ja auch immer wieder. Aber so Optionen gibt es ja auch noch an der Börse. Also diese Optionen ist ja ein Ding, was es auch noch für ganz andere, also für, was weiß ich. Na gut, du kannst ja auf alles eine Option machen. Schweine lenden. getreide zum Beispiel, ja. Genau.
Also im grunde ist es ein Vertrag, wo der eine Partner einwillig zu einem gegebenen, festgelegten Zeitpunkt eine Aktie, eine bestimmte Aktie einer bestimmten Firma, zu einem ebenfalls festgelegten Wertpreis zu kaufen oder zu verkaufen. Es gibt Kaufs- und Verkaufsoptionen. Und der Trick ist jetzt, dass die Option selbst einen Preis hat und handelbar ist. Das heißt, wenn wir sagen, wir haben eine Option, die läuft irgendwie fünf Jahre und die geht davon aus, dass ich in der Zukunft eine, was weiß ich, Telekom-Aktie kaufen kann, zu dem Doppelten des heutigen Preises, dann ist sie natürlich nichts wert, außer die Telekom ist noch mehr gewachsen, als sich verdoppelt zu haben.
Das heißt, das ist halt eigentlich eine Wette.
Eigentlich ist es eine Wette und das ist, ist aber nicht als Wette erfunden worden, sondern als Absicherung. Also die idee ist, nehmen wir mal an, ich bin jetzt ein Fonds oder ich bin Rentenversicherung.
Lass uns mal einfach anfangen, du bist ein Farmer.
Ursprünglich geht es darum, dass die Ernte nicht vorhersagbar ist beim Bauern. Und wenn die, ob die jetzt ausfällt oder nicht und ob man so viel erntet und vor allem, wie der Preis sein wird, ist nicht vorhersagbar. Deswegen ist es für Bauern wichtig, so eine kalkulierbare Größe zu haben und deswegen verkaufen die ein Teil von ihrem getreide, bevor sie es geerntet haben, zu einem Festpreis. Und wenn sie Glück haben, dann ist der eigentliche Preis von Weizen, wenn es dann soweit ist, tiefer. Wenn sie Pech haben, dann haben sie trotzdem Planungssicherheit gehabt und deswegen ist das trotzdem okay für den Farmer.
Ja, und sie können damit halt, wenn sie die Optionen schon rechtzeitig verkaufen können, durchaus einfach auch umgehen, dass sie Kredite aufnehmen müssen.
Und lustigerweise, man macht es nicht für den gesamten erwarteten Ernteeintrag, sondern man behält noch ein bisschen. Genau, und was man dann einlöst, das reicht dann eben, um einem finanzielle Sicherheit zu geben, aber mit dem Rest kann man eventuell noch massiv Profit machen.
Interessanter daran ist, dass das ja erst möglich wurde, nachdem getreide standardisiert wurde. Also dass es halt klar war, dass du halt nicht irgendwie Pharma-Jaws irgendwie spezial weizen von irgendwo da hinten, sondern dass es erst möglich wurde, nachdem eben ja es standardisiert wurde.
Seit wir alle Monsanto-Mais haben.
Naja, beziehungsweise halt irgendwie, da gibt es halt diese Sorten, die halt irgendwie gehandelt werden, die dann auch zu bestimmten Zeiten eben in den handel kommen und wo dann eigentlich auch egal ist, weil dann kannst du halt einfach zum Silo gehen und da irgendwie deine 50 Tonnen reinkippen und dann kriegst du halt einen Zettel, auf dem steht, du hast gerade 50 Tonnen Winterweizen Sorte 3 eingeliefert. Und mit dem Zettel kannst du dann zur Börse gehen und sagen, hier, diese sind jetzt mal da und damit kann man jetzt handeln. So und das heißt also diese...
Da gibt es übrigens einen Fachbegriff hier, das nennt sich fungibile Güter, wenn ein Gut austauschbar ist. Also wenn es da keine qualitätsunterschiede oder Bauartprobleme gibt.
Da gibt es übrigens auch noch so lustige Probleme, weil so gerade so bei getreide gibt es natürlich so eine gewisse Bandbreite von Qualität. Da gibt es halt eine Definition von, das ist jetzt hier irgendwie Winterweizen-Qualität 2, die sich halt um die Korngröße und Härte und Wassergehalt und so erstreckt. Und wenn du jetzt halt dir genau die Grenzen nimmst und anfängst in den Silos zu mischen, dann kannst du genau wie halt mit zum Beispiel, wie wir es mal behatten, bei diesen Colour-Damage-Obligations da, die hin und her mixen.
Also es gibt auch ganz witzige Effekte, die sich daraus ergeben, weil in den Optionen steht auch drin, welche Qualitätsklasse. Und den Rest, den nimmt man an sich für Viehfütterung. Das ist immer so die ausrede, warum man den zurückgehalten hat. Und jetzt war es halt so, dass die Preise sich deutlich höher nach oben entwickelt haben, als man vorher gesehen hat. Und dass deswegen der Viehfütterungsweizen am ende eine deutlich bessere Qualität hatte, als der für die menschliche Fütterung, den man...
Hast du ihn einfach oben schlüpfen lassen?...
und dann hat man... Naja, nee, aber das war dann... Also solche Effekte passieren eben. Also ursprünglich war das als Absicherung gedacht und später hat man es dann als Absicherung für Aktienkäufe genommen. Da ist dann die idee, wenn ich jetzt 1000 Aktien kaufe von einer bestimmten Firma und ich glaube, dass sie nach oben gehen, aber es könnte auch sein, dass sie nach unten gehen und ich darf kein zu hohes Risiko eingehen, zum Beispiel, weil ich ein Rentenfonds bin oder so. Dann könnte man sich ja überlegen, dass man sich irgendwie absichert und entweder man macht halt eine Versicherung oder man macht so eine Wette in die Gegenrichtung. Das ist jetzt nicht erlaubt für einen Rentenfonds. Das dürfen nur Hedgefonds. Deswegen heißen die auch Hedgefonds, denn diese Risikoabfangung über eine Gegenwette heißt Hedging. Das ist eigentlich genau der Unterschied zwischen einem Fonds, der keine Risikogeschäfte macht und einem Hedgefonds, der sie eben doch macht.
Aber machen denn nicht auch alle möglichen anderen Firmen solche Geschäfte und sich zum Beispiel gegen Währungsrisiken abzusichern? Ja.
Genau.
Wie funktioniert das denn? Wie die Firmen das machen. Also wie meine Schnürsäckefabrik irgendwie kauft irgendwie den Flux irgendwie einen Dollar ein.
Na es gibt auch Optionen auf indexer und auf Währungskurse.
Also du nimmst quasi Zertifikate, die deinem Ziel nahekommen. Du sagst einfach, also beim Euro-Dollar will ich mich bei, was weiß ich, 1,50 absichern. Also mehr will ich da einfach nicht bezahlen. Und dann musst du dir halt ausrechnen, wie das mit den Zertifikaten oder Optionen, die dir zur Verfügung stehen, hinzubekommen ist. Das machen natürlich auch wieder die Banken für den Gern. Das heißt also, wenn ich jetzt, also nehmen wir mal an, ich weiß halt irgendwie, ich muss für 100.000 Dollar irgendwie Flux kaufen pro Jahr, um eine Schnürsäcke zu produzieren, dann rechne ich mir aus, wenn der Dollar-Kurs irgendwie, keine Ahnung, unter uns... Also du investierst Kapital, um abzusichern, dass du im Worst Case nicht noch viel mehr Kapital investieren müsstest. Okay, aber na, lass mal konkret machen. Also ich muss halt für 100.000 Dollar irgendwie Flux kaufen, das weiß ich ungefähr, so mit den Preisen, egal wie die fluktuieren. Und wenn der Dollar-Euro-Kurs sich für mich ungünstig entwickelt, also keine Ahnung, er geht jetzt auch plötzlich auf 1,10 oder so, also dass nur noch der Dollar noch 1,10 wert ist, dann muss ich plötzlich mehr Euro dafür ausgeben, für meinen Flux. Und das will ich irgendwie vermeiden. Also dann rechne ich mir aus, wie viel ich mehr bezahlen müsste und kaufe für dieses, also im Höhe dieses Betrages eine Gegenwette. Ja, genau. Also du brauchst, du musst irgendwo wissen, wo deine Schmerzgrenze ist und an der setzt du dann an und kaufst dir dafür die entsprechenden Produkte, die dich dort absichern. Damit kannst du dich natürlich dann auch wieder verhauen, wenn es in die andere Richtung läuft. Also das ist dann schon Geld, was du auch einsetzt.
Deswegen macht man die Absicherung auch normalerweise nicht zu 100 Prozent. Ja, denn das kostet Geld und das Geld, was so eine Option kostet, richtet sich danach für wie wahrscheinlich der Markt es hält, dass es eintritt. Ja, und deswegen nimmt man normalerweise ein Limit, wo es dann wirklich wehtun würde und das Risiko bis dahin federt man selber ab. Ja, das heißt ja, wenn man sich tatsächlich zu 100 Prozent absichern wollte, dann riskiert man eben auch kein Gewinn zu machen, wenn es eben nicht in diese Phase reinläuft. Deswegen so ein richtig perfekter Absicherungen macht man eigentlich nicht.
Und was war jetzt mit diesem Porsche und VW? Das waren noch auch solche Absicherungsoptionen?
Na, das war eine ganz witzige Angelegenheit. Da ging es nämlich so, dass Porsche VW kaufen wollte, was historisch gesehen schon mal witzig ist, weil VW eigentlich eine ausgliederung von Porsche war, wo es darum ging, den Käfer eigentlich in Porsche designen, als Volkswagen zu bauen. Also Porsche wollte VW kaufen und das Problem bei VW ist, die sind zwar börsennotiert, aber ein Großteil der Aktien ist eben in Staatsbesitz oder in Besitz von Leuten.
landesbesitz in niedersachsen, ne?
Ja.
Zehn Prozent oder ein Zwanzig?
Nee, das war richtig viel. Ich hab's jetzt auch nicht im Kopf.
Die haben eine feststehende Kurs.
Es gab überhaupt nur 30 Prozent, die frei am Markt handelbar war. Und die Porsche-Financiers haben halt so einen Spezialisten eingestellt, der hat dann angefangen, die ganzen Optionen zu kaufen. Und das haben sie halt nicht als einer gemacht, sondern als mehrere Firmen, sodass denen die Optionen, die die Optionen verkauft haben, nicht klar war, dass hier einer versucht, alle Porsche-Aktien zu kaufen. sondern das hat niemand gemerkt, bis es dann soweit war. Als der Termin kam, haben sie eben die Aktien eingefordert.
Das heißt, der hat die...
Auch unter dem, auch wenn sie Verlust gemacht hätten.
Lass mal das kurz noch mal klar machen. Was der getan hat, ist, der hat Leuten, die dachten, sie können zu dem Zeitpunkt, wenn diese Option gezogen wird, sagen, okay, dann gehen wir los und kaufen die Aktien, um die dem zu liefern.
Genau. Und die wussten halt nicht, dass er die ganzen anderen Aktien auf dem Markt zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon gekauft haben wird.
Das ist doch das, was man eigentlich eine Market Corner nennt, hm?
Genau. So, und was jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass sie das irgendwann gemerkt haben, als es zu spät war und mussten dann ihren Arsch bedecken und Aktien von irgendwo kriegen. Und die drei Leute, die noch Porsche-Aktien hatten, VW-Aktien hatten an der Stelle, die haben sie behalten, weil sie natürlich gesehen haben, boah, der Aktienkurs geht hier gerade nach oben. Ist ja klar, wenn eine riesige Nachfrage ist, aber keiner verkauft, geht der Kurs nach oben. Und es war so, dass in dem Jahr irgendwie der DAX zu 20 Prozent, oder was nur von diesem, also die DAX-Steigerung nur auf diesen VW-Kurs zurückzuführen war, der sich da irgendwie, was war das, 100-facht hat oder so, also völlig unglaubliche Kursspirale. Es war so richtig...
Porsche ist nicht im DAX-Kurs.
Nee, nicht Porsche, VW.
VW, ja.
Und der VW-Kurs ging halt so...
Genau. Ja, die haben uns in der Finanzkrise tatsächlich einen Arsch gerettet im DAX. Also das hat ganz gut getan. Also für die Leute, die sozusagen auf den dax-index gewinnt haben. Also das war schon faszinierend. Ich habe kurz noch mal nachgeschaut, 12,7 Prozent hält niedersachsen. An Volkswagen nicht Porsche, da müssen wir aufpassen. Und VW ist glaube ich damals bis auf 1000 Euro gelaufen.
Und vorher waren sie so um die 100, oder wie war die vorher? Im Moment sind sie so 150.
Im Tief habe ich mich noch in Erinnerung, habe ich mal bei 30 Euro mit denen über die diskutiert.
Hättest du mal gekauft und nicht diskutiert.
Okay, gut. Aber so viel Glück hat man. Das heißt also der Typ, der das für Porsche gemacht hat, hat also eine Market Corner aufgebaut, indem er dafür gesorgt hat, dass die Leute, die ihm Optionen verkauft haben, nicht liefern können.
Na, das war nicht seine Intention dabei natürlich.
Das heißt, der hat verkackt.
Nein, wieso? Dem kann es doch egal sein. Der kriegt ja seine Aktien. Ob die anderen Probleme haben?
Ne, bloß, also die offensichtliche Sache, die er zu dem Zeitpunkt hätte tun sollen, wäre seine restlichen Foswär-Aktien für 1000 Euro verkaufen.
Na, vielleicht hat er das gemacht.
Okay, aber warum ist denn... Also er hat sie nicht verkauft. Soviel können wir glaube ich sagen. Okay.
Na, vielleicht hatte er privat irgendwie noch eine Sammlung.
Aber ich meine, dann hätten sie es doch hinterher für Cash kaufen können.
Ja.
Also, man muss ein bisschen dazu sagen, also die Kurse um 1000, das war jetzt auch nicht wirklich viel Umsatz da oben. Das war so ein kurzer Blow-off, wie man es so schön nennt. Und dann ist es auch schon wieder runtergegangen. Es gab halt auch einen Haufen Leute, die waren short in dieser Aktie. Also weil halt jeder immer gesagt hat, der Kurs ist zu hoch. Und da sind dann so diese ganzen Professionals, wie man sie so schön nennt, hatten alle ihre Short-Positionen. Und die hat es halt alle zerrupft. Deswegen ist auch der Kurs mit so hoch geschossen, weil die halt alle kaufen mussten. Und dann haben die Aktien gefehlt. Also Short heißt, sie haben halt diese Aktien verkauft, obwohl sie nicht hatten und mussten die dann liefern. Ja. Super. Und warum ist das dann trotzdem eigentlich schiefgegangen? Also warum hat, weil Porsche das nicht finanziert bekommen hat. Ach so, sie haben also die haben massive, die haben sich einfach überhoben. Vor allen Dingen, weil ja dann mit der Finanzkrise auch die Bewertungsansätze völlig anders geworden sind. Also VW hat sich zwar gehalten und die haben das in ihrer Bilanz immer so schön als At Equity nennt man das. Also immer schön mit dem Börsenkurs bewertet und dadurch riesige Gewinne ausgewiesen. Plus operativ stand halt gar nichts dahinter. Und denen sind ja dann auch die Absätze eingebrochen. Und dann haben halt die Banken irgendwann gesagt, also Jungs, so geht es nicht. Und dann war auf einmal wieder VW am Zug. Ja, wir retten euch jetzt mal. So haben dann den Spieß umgedreht. Das ist eine witzige Geschichte. Diese Market Corner gibt es ja schon sehr lange. Und die damals in Chicago war, da ging es erst vorbei, als sie angefangen haben, die Vorräte in den Silos transparent zu machen. Das heißt, die mussten dann alle an Markt beteiligten Firmen einmal die Woche sagen, wie viel sie eigentlich haben.
Das ist ja auch super.
Also, wenn man das halt funktioniert halt.
Transparenz.
Ja, also damit du halt sehen kannst, wenn jemand sich da halt Positionen aufbaut, also Optionspositionen aufbaut, die dann halt dazu führen, dass es halt eine Market Corner gibt. Und die leittragenden bei damals in Chicago waren halt natürlich die Farmer. So, weil wenn halt so eine Market Corner vorbei war, dann war natürlich der Preis für den entsprechenden Weizen oder was auch immer total im Arsch. Und sie haben dann halt natürlich auch keinen, ja ihren realen Weizen nicht mehr losgefahren, weil die alle keinen Bock mehr auf diesen, boah, haben uns gerade die Finger verbrannt.
Wir sind auf Rocken umgestiegen. Ja, das ist aber keine antike Sache, das gibt es immer noch. Es gab hier letztes Jahr, oder wann war das, diese Kakao-Geschichte. Aber es gibt alle paar Jahre wieder so eine Meldung, dass irgendeine...
Das ist auch nicht nur auf die Börse beschränkt, man hat auch immer wieder das Apple sowas gerne macht, einfach mal so alle Komponenten vom Markt zu kaufen, damit die anderen dann nicht produzieren können. Das ist ja vom Prinzip her quasi das Gleiche. In China hab ich dann... Wann war das? Vor zwei Jahren oder so. Da haben die sich halt auch mal irgendwann die Lagerhallen vollgestopft und dann die Kupferpreise nach oben getrieben. Also passiert immer wieder so ein ganz gängiges Spiel, dass...
Und in der Presse heißt es, dass dann immer eine Fabrik sei geplatzt?
Bei Aktien ist es tatsächlich verboten. Also da gab es in Deutschland vor, das ist auch, glaube ich, auch schon wieder zwei Jahre her, gab es tatsächlich mal einen Fall, wo das im Zuge einer Kapitalerhöhung völlig schiefgelaufen ist und dann einer da alle vor sich hergetrieben hat. Auch so ein Schweizer Pennystock natürlich. Das wurde alles rückabgewickelt.
Echt?
Also so weit sind wir dann zumindest bei uns schon mal. Also dass solche Sachen... Interessant. Ja, wo sind wir jetzt weiter?
Wir haben hier noch ein paar Beispiele. Man kann auch in beide Richtungen Optionen kaufen. Also eine Option ist ja eine Wette, dass man glaubt, der Kurs geht entweder nach oben oder nach unten. Und man kann auch in beide Richtungen wetten. Und dann macht man halt Kohle, außer der Kurs bleibt stabil. Das gibt es auch. Also man glaubt, diese Aktie ist sehr volatil, die geht auf jeden Fall los.
Aber es heißt auch, dass es dann einen Multiplikationsfaktor geben muss bei der Wette, damit du in jede Richtung gewinnen musst.
Ja, die Option selber kostet normalerweise nicht viel. Also wie viel die kostet, richtet sich halt danach, wie wahrscheinlich das Ereignis ist. Das heißt, am meisten Kohle kannst du mit sowas machen, wenn du insiderwissen hast. Das ist natürlich verboten, aber so kommt es halt immer wieder vor.
Wie ist denn das mit insiderhandel? Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie mir so gerade die so kleinere Aktiengesellschaften angucke, wie soll denn da jemand der Versuchung widerstehen, halt irgendwie nicht sein Wissen zu Geld zu machen?
Na ich würde gar nicht mal in der Firma gucken, ehrlich gesagt, sondern dieses ganze Börsenapparat. Nehmen wir mal an, du gehst zu deiner Bank und sagst du möchtest jetzt, was weiß ich, 5000 so und so Aktien kaufen. Und die Bank wollte eh auch noch 100 kaufen, dann kauft sie natürlich erst mal deine, um den Wert nach oben zu treiben. Kauft sie erst ihre eigene, dann geht der Wert nach oben mit deinem größeren Deal und dann verkauft sie ihre eigenen wieder und hat ein kleines Geschäft gemacht.
Das nennt sich Frontrunning.
Das nennt sich Frontrunning und das ist natürlich illegal.
Außer wenn Kurtmann Sexus macht.
Das ist ja erst illegal geworden, nachdem die Leute das gemacht haben. Die ganzen Regeln sind ja nicht vom Himmel gefallen.
Bei dem Spiel ist ja nicht das Problem, die Banken, zumindest nicht in Deutschland. Da gibt es ja auch diese, diese Shines Wall nennt sich das, wo die Abteilung da keine Information von der anderen bekommt. Das klappt. Also ich will nicht sagen, dass es immer klappt, aber das klappt halbwegs. In Deutschland ist da mehr das Problem, da sind wir schon wieder bei den Schweizer Pendingstocks. Man landet immer dort.
Was ist das denn mit den Schweizern, sag mal?
Du kannst halt in der Schweiz so eine kleine AG mit sehr wenig Geld gründen, die dann einen Nennwert von 0,001 Schweizer Franken hat. Dann hast du dann halt so ein paar Millionen Aktien von dem Kram, je nachdem, wie groß du das Ding machst, bringst du da irgendeinem Bauernhof aus Deutschland beispielsweise rein. Also da stehen dann schon so ein quasi reales Konzept dahinter. Und dann gibt es so irgendwelche Spam-Server in Venezuela und sonst wo, die dann überall verkünden, was für tolle Übernahmen dieses Unternehmen gleich machen wird und wie geil das ist. Und Kohlchance eine Million Prozent. Und wenn du dann halt deine Aktien für 0,001 Schweizer Franken je Stück in deinem Depot hast und so ein Ding auf nur 10 Cent steigt, hast du halt einen richtig guten Deal gemacht, bloß die steigen auch gerne nochmal weiter. Also das Extremste, was ich bei so einem Teil erlebt habe, war irgendwie so 25 Euro. Da gibt es ja bestimmt auch noch höhere. Also die nur von Spam hochgetrieben wurden. Die nur von Spam und also wo nicht wirklich was dahinter steht. Naja, ich hab mir das mal angeguckt, also mal nach Stockspam geguckt und dann erzählt sich mal ein Freund, der arbeitet bei einem größeren Hersteller von so einem Mailfilter-Software, also die halt einfach E-Mail filtern für Firmen. Also für die Prozessen, ich glaube, jede stunde 25 Millionen E-Mails. Davon ist natürlich irgendwie ein großer Teil Spam und die haben ziemlich viele verteilte Notes, also sie kriegen den Kram auch weltweit. Und die haben dann sich mal Filter gebaut, dafür, dass sie feststellen, ob sie früh in so einer Spamwelle drin sind. Also, dass sie die Spamwelle sehen, bevor sie, also wenn sie gerade anläuft, haben dann automatisch irgendwie für 10 Euro diese Aktien gekauft und sich dann angeguckt, bis wann die Kurven hochgehen, statistisch, und dann automatisch wieder verkauft. Also, hat zu sagen, diese Spamwelle mitgeritten und dann wieder verkauft. Am ende haben sie sich dann halt irgendwie davon immer ihr Betriebsgrill festfinanziert. So sind halt schon so paar tausend Euro im Jahr zusammengekommen damit. Also, so Spiele kommen natürlich damit.
Ist natürlich auch illegal.
Wieso ist es illegal?
Na, weil das insiderwissen ist.
Das ist eine interessante Frage, ob das nicht insiderwissen ist. Das Spam kann kein insiderwissen sein. Es ist nur Timing, es ist nur Market Timing. Es ist also auf jeden Fall weniger illegal als zum Beispiel dieses Frontrannigen, was Goldman Sachs gemacht hat.
Weniger illegal. Der Satz, der Ausdruck des Tages, war gleich mal Marhat-Trigger, das ist überhaupt nicht ein Neusprechblock.
Also ich würde, Goldman Sachs hat ja da offensichtlich solche Sachen gemacht, wie der Pressentnehmen war, dass sie dann so wenige hundert millisekunden vor dem eigentlichen trade automatisch noch ihren eigenen trade eingefügt haben.
Na, die laufen eh außer Konkurrenz, oder?
Naja, so was wie viel das angeht, auf jeden Fall.
Die sind so auf Ebene der katholischen Kirche.
Darauf weht er. Na gut, aber richtiges insider-training ist ja eigentlich mehr sowas wie, da gibt es halt noch eine Kapitalerhöhung oder die Firma hat einen großen Auftrag bekommen oder verloren oder so eine Sache, also Sachen, die halt großrelevant sind. Ja, und du siehst es auch, wenn man sich sehr viele Charts anschaut von diversen Unternehmen, dann sieht man auch, komischerweise gehen immer vor den Zahlen die Kurse nach oben oder wenn irgend so eine News rauskommt, dann geht erst der Kurs hoch und dann auf einmal ist eine News da. Das zu beweisen ist natürlich fast nicht möglich. Also wenn es denn nicht der Chef selber ist, der da handelt, weil mittlerweile ist es ja so, dass die behörden unsere Konto- oder Depot-Umsätze durchaus mal nachschauen können.
Ach, wie deine, weil du in der Branche tätig bist? oder weil du ein AG-Chef bist?
Normale Bankenüberwachung. Also die behörden auf sich und die BaFin, beziehungsweise die BaFin kann das dann, glaube ich, die können beim Verdachtsmoment da reinschauen. Das ist eine anforderung.
Auf insidertraining.
anforderungen an die Banken. Da gucken die mal nach. Davon kriegst du auch nichts mit, wenn du dich nicht aktiv bei deiner Bank dann darum bemühst, rauszufinden, ob die mal nachgefragt haben. Also das wird einfach gemacht und hinten runterfallen gelassen.
Also der amerikanische Ansatz ist, dass man als insider, und dazu gehört eben Apermanagement in so einer Firma, vorher öffentlich bekannt geben muss bei der SEC. Und die tut es dann ins Web, wenn man Beträge von seinen eigenen Firmen, Aktien kaufen oder verkaufen will.
Das sind ja diese...
Das nennt sich dann auch insider-trading und das ist halt der nicht verbotene Teil. Weil du bist ja immer noch ein insider und tradest immer noch. Und die ist ja nicht verboten, mit deinen Aktien zu traden. Du musst es nur bekannt geben, damit die anderen, wenn sie schlau genug sind, eben das auch lesen und dann auch schnell machen.
Wenn du einen guten Freund hast, sagst du, geben wir es ja vielleicht doch noch.
Es gab da eine coole Statistik drüber, von einer Weile, wo die halt mal geguckt haben und wo die Gruppe, die am meisten Profit gemacht hat, waren US-Senatoren.
Was?
Ja, das war so ganz witzig. Weil die halt, naja gut, also das war das.
Interessant war da auch die Statistik, dass jetzt offensichtlich von den company-insiders, also den Leuten, die es wissen müssen, gerade sehr viel mehr Leute ihre Aktien verkaufen als kaufen. Also normalerweise sagt man wohl so irgendwie, dass der gesunde Level ist, irgendwie so ein bisschen mehr verkaufen als kaufen, so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so 60 Prozent oder so. Mehr verkaufen als kaufen. Und momentan ist es wohl so, dass nur noch 7 Prozent kaufen, der Rest ist verkaufen in den SEC-Fightings. Also das Problem bei diesen insider-handel-beobachtungen, die gibt es ja in Deutschland auch. Also Directors Dealings nennt sich das bei uns. ordentliches Deutsch. Und man kann daraus nicht wirklich einen Schluss ziehen. Also ich habe jetzt verschiedene Studien mal gelesen darüber im Laufe der Jahre. Also so richtig richtig liegen die nicht. Also das ist eher so ein Kontraindikator. Was die einzelne Firma angeht. Wenn die kaufen, ist die Chance eher so, dass die Aktie dann fällt.
Was auch durchaus Absicht ist, denn es kommt nämlich vor, dass die denken, oh wir haben hier schlechte Nachrichten zu verkünden. Wie können wir denn mal ausdrücken, dass wir trotzdem noch an unsere Firma glauben?
Und dann machen sie bei mir.
Und dann machen sie schnell noch einen Kauf. Die Firma selbst kann das natürlich tun und dann eine Presseerklärung machen, dass die Aktienrückkäufe machen. Aber es können halt auch insider machen und die nutzen das dann als Informationskanal.
Hintergrund ist natürlich auch, dass der Aktienkurs sehr wichtig ist für die ganzen Boni von vorständen. Also der ist ja nicht nur immer an Umsatz und Gewinn gekoppelt, sondern auch an Aktienkurs-Erreichungsziele. Keine Ahnung, wie man das nennt. Aber normalerweise ist es ja so, das ist so ein Aspekt, den wir vorhin weggelassen haben. Es gibt ja auf einer Aktie noch eine dividende. Also wenn ich in meiner Schnürsengefabrik jetzt ordentlichen Gewinn mache, dann zahl ich in all meine 100 Aktionäre irgendwie einen Euro pro Aktie oder 10 Cent pro Aktie dividende aus. Aber irgendwie hört man von dieser dividende nicht mehr so richtig viel. Also zumindest so werden gerade die höchsten dividenden aller Zeiten ausgeschüttet. Zwischendurch war es doch eher so, dass die Firmen gesagt haben, ne wir zahlen lieber keine dividende, wir kaufen lieber unsere Aktien zurück, um den Aktienkurs nach oben zu treiben. Also Thema dividende haben wir hier irgendwo drinstehen.
Ich glaube wir haben es nicht nur zählt.
Doch, doch, doch. Mehrmals sogar. Also es ist so, dass, erklären wir erstmal dividende, oder? Es ist so, dass Firmen, es gibt einen Bilanzposten namens Bilanzgewinn. Wenn der im positiven Bereich ist, dann kann eine Firma eine dividende ausschütten. Es gibt da so zwei, drei Ausnahmen, aber die lassen wir dir einfach halber mal weg. Du kannst dann sagen, was weiß ich, deine Aktie ist ein Euro wert und du zahlst 10 Cent dividende. Dann hast du eine schöne dividendenrendite von 10 Prozent. Das sieht nach außen hin so ein bisschen nach Verzinsung der Anlage aus. Erfreut den Mensch komischerweise. Es ist aber so, dass der Normalbürger darauf 25 Prozent Abgeltungssteuer zahlen muss. Auf dividende. Auf dividende und Fonds zahlen glaube ich nichts und Firmen zahlen 5 Prozent. Und das heißt, du kriegst Geld, musst es aber versteuern und gleichzeitig wird die dividende auch vom Aktienkurs abgezogen. Wie? Also wenn du jetzt, wenn deine Aktie ein Euro wert ist und du 10 Cent dividende ausschüttest, dann geht der Kurs, dann einfach 10 Cent abgezogen. Das heißt, der handel beginnt dann bei 0,90. Warum? Ja, weil die Firma ja Geld ausgeschüttet hat, aus ihrem eigenen Kapitel. Aber die Aktie ist doch eigentlich mehr so ein Wertschätzungdienst. Du kannst die ja dann auch wieder hochkaufen, wenn du willst. Aber rein mathematisch muss die halt rausgerechnet werden. Das macht denn die Börse oder wer macht das? Das läuft dann voll automatisch über die Abwicklungsstellen. Die teilen das dann mit. Da gibt es dann in Deutschland die Wertpapiermitteilungen nennt sich das. Das ist WM-Daten, steht dahinter, also Wirtschaftsmitteilungen. Die verlegen auch die Börsenzeitungen und das ist irgendwie so von Banken gestützt. Und keine Ahnung genau, wie die sich finanzieren. Aber die verteilen dann an die Banken die ganzen dividendeninformationen über dividenden, Kapitalerhöhungen und sonst noch was. So und das wird dann halt vom Kurs abgezogen. Das heißt also rein mathematisch ist das ein eher negatives Geschäft. Dadurch, dass aber irgendwie jeder zu denken scheint oder dass einfach dieser Mythos vorherrscht, dass das irgendwie eine Art Verzinsung wäre, erfinden es alle ganz geil und bestehen auf ihre dividende. Und dadurch steigt dann der Kurs im Vorfeld von dividendenzahlungen. Und auch so generell sind diese Aktien für die Mehrheit der Menschen irgendwie attraktiver. Also ich kann es mathematisch nicht nachvollziehen.
Das ist ja auch so, dass das Geld nicht mehr für Investitionen zur Verfügung steht. Richtig.
Also dem Unternehmen fehlt dieses Geld. Es kann nicht mehr investieren. oder kann nur weniger investieren. Und ich zahle noch Steuern drauf. Aber es gab doch mal, ich kann mich deutlich erinnern, bei der letzten Start-up-Blase war es so, dass dividenden, das wurde überhaupt nicht diskutiert, sondern da ging es nur darum, weil die alle Verluste hatten. Nee, aber da ging es nur darum, dass wir nie mal Gewinn gemacht haben, dass der denn in ein Aktienrückkaufprogramm investiert wurde, um den Aktienkurs nach oben zu treiben, mit dem Argument, dass damals auf Kurssteigerungen die Steuern halt geringer waren als auf die dividende. Für einen Aktienrückkauf brauchst du keinen Gewinn. Den kannst du einfach so machen als Firma, wenn du das Geld hast. Und diese ganzen Start-ups, die haben alle riesen Verluste gehabt, die irgendwie dividendenfähig mal, also die meisten Leute gegangen. Aber die paar wenigen, die es geschafft haben, haben das auch irgendwie... Na aber selbst Cisco oder so hat das ja so gemacht. Die haben ja auch irgendwie jahrelang keine dividende gezahlt, sondern immer Buyback-Programme gemacht. Eben mit der Begründung, dass es für ihre Investoren günstiger sei, wenn der Aktienkurs steigt. Weil wenn sie dann raus sind, selbst wenn sie dann verkaufen, dass sie dann die Gewinne weniger versteuern müssen, als wenn sie dividende versteuern müssen. Es ist nicht Usus, dass man das mit der Begründung nur ein Aktienrückkaufprogramm macht. So ein Aktienrückkaufprogramm, um das noch kurz zu erklären. Eine Hauptversammlung kann beschließen, das wird meistens über einen Vorratsbeschluss gemacht, der mittlerweile...
Vorratsbeschluss, das klingt nach Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Irgendwie alles, was Vorrat hat, ist irgendwie negativ beliebt.
Na ja, du hast halt in dem Moment keinen konkreten Anlass zu sagen, ich möchte jetzt morgen ein Aktienrückkaufprogramm machen.
Ist halt so eine Art Blankoscheck.
Genau. sondern du sagst einfach, ich will irgendwann mal vielleicht ein Aktienrückkaufprogramm machen und das will ich mir jetzt von euch genehmigen lassen. Seit kurzem gelten die Beschlüsse für fünf Jahre. Früher waren das, glaube ich, anderthalb. Das heißt, einem die die HV beschließt und dann kann das Unternehmen fünf Jahre lang zurückkaufen und zwar bis zu zehn Prozent. Und da gibt es dann wieder irgendwelche Einschränkungen von wegen der Durchschnittskurs der letzten fünf Börsentage und ähnlichen Kram. Also damit die da nicht zu abstrusen Kursen sich die Akzente kaufen und am besten noch sie selber dann abkaufen.
Ja, aber das wäre ja korrupt. Das gibt es doch nicht bei uns.
Nicht in Deutschland, nein. Aber in Deutschland gibt es ja irgendwie noch so komische andere Formen, sowas wie Genussscheine. Das ist was hier vom Wert… Das ist ein Finanzierungsding. Das hat nichts mit… Na ja, aber ich kriege ja dann auch irgendwann eine Ausschüttung auf diese Genussscheine. Naja, also das ist vom Kunstwirk.
Das hängt als Erhabung in der S-Bahn aus übrigens. Daher finde ich das wichtig, dass wir das mal ansprechen.
Genau, erzähl mal, wie funktionieren die? Also Genussscheine ist… Ist eigentlich mehr so eine Anleihe. Ja, aber mit einem entscheidenden Nachteil. Also du gibst einem Unternehmen Geld und kriegst dafür eine meist überdurchschnittliche Rendite.
Allerdings nur?
Ja, allerdings gibt es dann immer so einen Zusatz. Es muss dies und das erreicht werden. Also zum Beispiel ein Gewinn. Da gibt es verschiedene modelle. Einfach ein Gewinn. oder du sagst also das Unternehmen muss mindestens 500.000 Euro im Jahr verdienen und alles darüber hinaus, da bekommt ihr dann eine entsprechende Rendite. oder was du dir halt alles sonst noch ausdenken kannst. Da sind deine Fantasie ja keine Grenzen gesetzt. So, jetzt ist es so, dass Genussscheine, also ich kenne sehr wenige, die funktioniert haben. Bei Genussscheinen ist das Problem, dass du ein volles Risiko eingehst. Also das Risiko eines Totalverlustes. Weil, wenn das Unternehmen beispielsweise pleite geht, ja, das muss man anders aufzäumen. Also wenn ein Unternehmen pleite geht, dann wird es in einem Insolvenzverfahren abgewickelt. Das heißt, alles wird verkauft, was geht, Geld eingetrieben, wo es halt noch zu holen ist. Und dann wird an die Gläubiger eine Quote ausgeschüttet. Diese Quote wird explizit nicht an Genussscheininhaber ausgeschüttet. Die bekommen erst dann Geld, wenn alle anderen Gläubiger befriedigt sind. Das heißt, dann hätte der Unternehmen wahrscheinlich auch nicht pleite gehen müssen, weil noch genug da gewesen wäre. Also genau, das ist ein Fall, den es eigentlich theoretisch nur geben kann. Aber praktisch wüsste ich jetzt nicht, wo er mal stattgefunden hätte. Das heißt, dein Geld ist weg, wenn das Unternehmen pleite ist. Und das heißt also, diese ganzen dubiosen Wind- und sonnenenergiebuden, die jetzt gerade ihre Genussscheine in die S-Bahn pflastern, sollte man wohl doch eher die Finger vorlassen. Ja genau, vor allen Dingen, weil sie ja tendenziell von Subventionen leben in der Branche. Und wie die sich entwickeln, ist ja auch immer so ein bisschen Willkür. Das heißt dann, ein regulatorisches Environment.
Das ist ein forward looking statement.
Und dann gibt es ja noch Anleihen. Anleihen sind ja, ich brauche dem Unternehmen Geld und bekomme dafür Anleihen. oder du kriegst Anleihen. Es gibt natürlich, also es gibt die meisten Anleihen, zumindest bei den größeren, werden gehandelt an der Börse. Das ist keine Kursnotierung, sondern eine Prozentnotierung. Das heißt, 100 Prozent ist der Ausgabekurs. Und so die Regel ist, wenn die Anleihe unter 100 Prozent geht, kannst du damit davon ausgehen, dass da Probleme herrschen in dem Unternehmen. Bei der Rückzahlung der Anleihen? Mit einem Anleihenkurs gibt es ein Bonitätsproblem. Das heißt also, du kaufst eine Anleihe, zeichnest die und kriegst auf die Anleihe einen vorher bestimmten Zinssatz. Ganz simpel. Und dasselbe machen ja auch Staaten. Das sind ja den sogenannten Staatsanleihen, über die wir gerade reden. Ah, kommen wir jetzt endlich zu Griechenland. Na ja, wenn wir schon mal bei Anleihen sind, dann können wir auch mal zu Griechenland kommen, oder? Ja, Staaten tun das auch. Sie zahlen nur nicht immer zurück. Wie funktioniert das? Das ist dann das, was man hier in Deutschland als bundes-schatzbriefe kennt, ne? Das ist doch so ungefähr diese, also... Ne, Schatzbriefe nicht, das ist doch nochmal was anderes. Du zahlst, du zeichnest schon bundes-, Staatsanleihen. Ja, Staatsanleihen, ja genau. Was heißt also, ich gehe hin und sage, hier, lieber bundesrepublik, hast du irgendwie von meinem teuren Aschner gingen? Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten. entweder du zeichnest tatsächlich so eine neue Mission, oder du gehst tatsächlich an die Börse und kaufst dort eine Anleihe, die schon gehandelt wird. Also die schon, wo jemand anders dem Staat schon das Geld gegeben hat? Ja, dann hast du natürlich anteiligen Zinsverlust zur nächsten Zahlung und so weiter. Aber du hast dafür natürlich auch die Möglichkeit dann, wenn du Glück hast oder Pech, unter 100 Prozent zu kaufen. Das heißt also, eine Anleihe ist eigentlich sowas Ähnliches wie Festgeld, nur dass ich nicht so ganz genau weiß, wie fest das Geld ist am ende für mich. Ich meine, um es so mal zu übersetzen. Das heißt also, diese handel mit den Staatsanleihen ist ja de facto deswegen so ein Indikator für die Bonität dieses Staates, weil der Kurs davon abhängt, wie wahrscheinlich es ist, dass ich das gesamte Geld zurück bekomme plus die Zinsen. Okay, und die sind halt dann zu bestimmten Fälligkeitsterminen? oder wie funktioniert das? Die Zinszahlung. Ja, da gibt es bestimmte Termine, wo dann einfach die Zinsen ausgezahlt werden. Und dann gibt es halt noch mal so ein Komplettabwicklungstermin, wo du dann deine Kohle zurückkriegst.
Wobei die Zinsen von Angebot und Nachfrage abhängen gar nicht mal davon, ob du glaubst, dass das natürlich gleich ist. Das ist ja letztendlich dasselbe.
Zur Emission einer Anleihe wird halt auch wieder so eine Auktion gemacht. Und dann sagen die halt, was weiß ich, ich gebe euch 3,5 Prozent. Und dann gibt es aber noch so eine Spanne, 3,5 bis 4. Und da findet sich dann irgendwo der Markt.
Also das spannende ist ja, dadurch, dass das von Angebot und Nachfrage abhängt, dass unsere Staatsanleihen attraktiver werden, preislich attraktiver, wenn die Griechenlands weniger attraktiv werden.
Wieso?
Also wenn Griechenland jetzt runtergraded wird, greifst du schon sehr, sehr weit vorweg. Naja, also nehmen wir mal an, Griechenland ist jetzt Junk-Status.
Nehmen wir mal an.
Völlig weit hergeholt. Also Junk-Status heißt, eine Rating-Agentur kommt und sagt, das ist scheiße, das kriegt ihr nicht zurück, das Geld.
Ihr kriegt das Geld nicht zurück, das heißt Junk-Status. Nö, das heißt so Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit 70 bis 90 Prozent.
Ja, das war was völlig anderes.
Ja, 10 Prozent hast du noch.
Also was dann passiert ist, dass institutionelle Anleger wie Versicherungen und Rentenfonds und so, die dürfen nur sehr bedingt frei investieren, sondern die haben so Risikotransen und da steht halt drin, keine Junk-Anleihen und da steht drin, je weniger Risiko es hat, desto höherer Prozentsatz von dem angelegten Geld darf sein. Das heißt, wenn so eine Staatsanleihe, die ja eigentlich der Inbegriff der sicheren Anleihe ist, die man bestimmt zurückkriegt, wenn die plötzlich als Junk-Status gilt, dann müssen sie das halt umschiften in ihrem Portfolio. Dann können sie das nicht mehr halten.
Das heißt, die müssen es verkaufen?
Die müssen es verkaufen. So was dann passiert ist natürlich. Der Preis geht runter von den Teilen und die Refinanzierung wird teurer für Griechenland, wenn die neue Kredite aufnehmen wollen. Was ja üblich ist, dass die, um die alten Kredite zurückzuzahlen, neue aufnehmen.
Das heißt dann Refinanzierung.
Genau.
Und wenn die schiefgeht?
Na ja, die geht ja nicht schief. Da wären nur die Zinsen astronomisch hoch. Wenn die ganz schief geht, dann nimmst du deine Notenbank und lässt die das kaufen. Das haben wir ja auch schon angeforen.
Es gibt halt immer so einen Zinssatz, den man dann irgendwann nicht mehr bezahlen kann.
Na ja, du druckst halt mehr Geld. Ist halt scheiße, wenn du in der Eurozone bist. Aber das hat sich ja auch bald erledigt. Also jedenfalls, was jetzt passiert, ist, dass die Leute, die die Griechenlandanleihen abgestoßen haben, dass die dann halt andere Anleihen kaufen müssen, weil sie ja die Betranche mit dem geringen Risiko anderweitig füllen müssen. Und da bleibt so viel und die gibt es halt nicht. Und die gehen dann halt in deutsche Anleihen. Das heißt, bei uns steigt die Nachfrage.
Damit können wir weniger Zinsen zahlen.
Und damit zahlen wir weniger Zinsen. Genau. Und das heißt, wir haben im letzten Jahr, du hattest da so eine Zahl?
Ja, als letztes Jahr, als Griechenland aktuell wurde. Also wir haben als Deutschland, damals, als diese Welle gab, knapp vier milliarden an Zinssalonen gespart. Einfach dadurch, dass wir für uns eine Neuverschuldung zahlen müssen. Ja, das ist natürlich der eine Effekt, dass die verkaufen und dann wieder woanders neu kaufen. Der andere Effekt ist natürlich, dass die Leute oder die Anlagegesellschaften generell dann so eine höhere Risiko-Aversität haben. Das heißt, die gehen dann einfach her und sagen, okay, heute kaufen wir nicht Griechenland, dann nehmen wir lieber Deutschland und haben uns weniger Prozent sicher, aber dafür halt die Anleihen. Und das sind dann halt so die Momente, wo wir als Deutschland tatsächlich effektiv Geld sparen. Und wir machen ja auch ständig irgendwelche Anleihenemissionen, weil wir uns refinanzieren müssen. Das ist ja so ein laufender Prozess.
So, und jetzt überlegt man sich doch an der Stelle, also ich zumindest, warum die Merkel eigentlich Griechenland nicht sanieren will, sondern dem, dem ihr im Weg steht. Und wenn man jetzt hört, dass Deutschland bzw. unser Haushalt effektiv Vorteile davon hat, dass Griechenland unsicher aussieht, dann ist das irgendwie schon so zusammenhangend, der bedenkenswert ist, finde ich an der Stelle.
Ja, also das ist das glaube ich nicht, dass die so ticken. Also bei Merkel oder bei uns in Deutschland ist das Problem.
Meinst du, sie ist nicht schlau genug?
Ja, das Problem ist...
Hey, die Frau studierte Physikerin, deren Doktorarbeit hat noch keine auseinandergedacht.
Ja, das ist ja auch ihr Lieblingsargum. Dass sie Physikerin ist. Nee, äh, es ist halt so, dass Deutschland tatsächlich bei dieser ganzen Griechenlandrettung der Bremsklotz ist, seit Anfang an. Und das aus freien wahltaktischen gründen. Also, ob das nun sinnig ist oder nicht, darüber können wir ja noch streiten, aber die haben unglaubliche Angst davor, mit diesen großen Summen in der Öffentlichkeit zu agieren und zu sagen, einfach mal auf den Tisch zu hauen. Also das, was der Finanzmarkt bräuchte. Komm, wir retten jetzt Griechenland und dann ist die Sache erledigt. stattdessen laborieren wir jetzt seit anderthalb Jahren an dem Ding rum. Aber ich meine, wenn ich so höre, der Finanzmarkt, also der Finanzmarkt hat ja eigentlich an dieser Griechenland-Krise echt ganz schön gut verdient, weil die, nachdem die irgendwie, die haben noch da irgendwie, was war diese Geschichte mit diesen Currency Default Swaps, die sich da installiert haben? Ja, also das ist so bescheuert. Also Griechenland ist auf Goldman Sachs so gegangen und hat gesagt, helft uns doch mal, unser Defizit hier zu schönen. Und dann hat Goldman die tolle idee gehabt, die aber wohl auch nicht neu war, einfach die Wiesen umzutauschen und einen fiktiven Währungskurs zu nehmen. Der Griechenland zum Stichtag wurde, wenn so ein Defizit festgestellt wird, halt mal so ein paar milliarden mehr bringt. Und das wurde dann halt kurz drauf wieder umgetauscht. Und Goldman hat, ja, also Griechenland hat dann wieder mehr schulden gehabt. Und Goldman hat noch eine ordentliche Provision verdient. Also vermutlich. Ich weiß nicht, ob das gelingen ist. Na gut, ich glaube nicht, dass Goldman irgendwas macht, ohne eine ordentliche Provision zu verdienen. Aber die Frage ist natürlich, also wenn jetzt der Finanzmarkt irgendwie verunsichert ist, wenn ich das schon wieder so lese, also wenn der Finanzmarkt jetzt verunsichert ist, dann ist er halt mal verunsichert. Das Problem ist, die Gewinne aus der Vergangenheit, das ist immer so eine schöne Floskel. Ihr habt ja milliarden verdient. Es hat halt jeder trotzdem so seine Probleme.
Ach, eine milliarde mehr könnte ich auch brauchen gerade.
Naja, das Problem liegt ja in der Refinanzierung, die ihr letztes Mal etwas breiter aufgeschlüsselt habt. Und dadurch, dass jeder halt immer so am Limit fährt, wie wir heute auch vom Bankenstresstest erlebt haben oder gehört haben, da kamen ja vorhin Ergebnisse. Wollten wir die nicht in der Einleitung nehmen? Ja, na, wir können es auch weiter hinschauen. Nee, die fahren halt alle am Limit mit ihren Krediten, also auch die Banken selber. Und wenn dann halt mal irgendwo so ein bisschen fehlt, haben die halt alle gleich ein Problem. Und das heißt also, wenn es dann heißt, der Finanzmarkt ist verunsichert, dann heißt es, dass wir so sehr am Limit sind, dass also wenn irgendwo was schiefgeht, dann geht es gleich richtig überall schief? oder was ist sozusagen die Dekodierung? Einige Institute arbeiten so und das Thema Hedgefonds ist ja sehr ähnliches.
Ja, das ist eher noch viel mehr. Wir haben ja letztes Mal aufgeschlüsselt, dass die Banken für die Kreditvergabe so einen Hebel haben. Dass sie, wie viel waren es jetzt, irgendwie 6 Prozent oder 4 Prozent oder so, vorhalten müssen an hartem Eigenkapital für Geld, was sie rausgeben. Und jetzt ändert sich halt durch der Übergang von Basel 2 zu Basel 3 die Quote, die sie vorhalten müssen. Aber die Kohle haben sie ja schon rausgegeben. Jetzt brauchen sie also mehr Eigenkapital und das muss jetzt kurzfristig irgendwo herkommen. Und wenn man das nicht hat, hat man halt ein Problem. Mit so großen Hebeln ist es auch nicht so, dass man dann mal eben großflächig liquidieren kann, sondern dann muss man halt wirklich großflächig liquidieren. Und bei Hedgefonds ist der Hebel noch größer, da hat man sowas wie Faktor 50. Also das ist schon, kann man sich vorstellen, wenn die auch nur mit einem Investment so ein bisschen daneben liegen, dann geht das ganze Kartenhaus weggeblasen.
Das heißt also, wenn es dann so heißt, jetzt die Finanzmärkte sind verunsichert, dann was würde dann eigentlich passieren? Also heißt das dann einfach bei der nächsten Staatsanleihen-Ausgabe, würden die halt einfach nicht mehr kaufen? oder was wurde eigentlich passiert?
Ich glaube, es ist so eine Floskel, wie die UNO beschwert sich über Menschenrechtsverletzung. Keine Auswirkung.
Naja, doch. Also es ist halt so, es ist halt so, wenn ich Staatsanleihen zeichne als Bank zum Beispiel, dann nehme ich diese Staatsanleihen, gehe zur EZB, hinterlege die als Sicherheiten und kriege dafür meine Kredite von der EZB, mit denen ich mich dann halt aufpumpe. Wenn nun meine griechischen Staatsanleihen ausfallen würden und die EZB sie dann halt nicht mehr als Sicherheit nimmt, dann fehlt mir in dem Moment erstmal Geld. Okay, das heißt also, diese Ansage von der EZB zu sagen, wir nehmen auch die griechischen Staatsanleihen, selbst wenn die Rating-Agenturen die Scheiße finden, ist erstmal eine klare Stabilisierungsmaßnahme, weil die Banken sich dann weiter Geld bei der EZB holen können.
Das heißt vor allem, dass sie sonst geplatzt werden.
Dabei geht es weniger um deutsche Banken oder französische. Gut, bei Frankreich ist es ein bisschen speziell, aber es geht halt hauptsächlich um die Banken, in den ländern, um die es auch geht. Also griechische Banken, irische Banken, Portugal ist auch schon drunter. Portugal, Spanien, ja.
Bist du sicher, dass das stimmt und nicht nur Propaganda von unseren Banken ist?
Nee, das verfolge ich tatsächlich jetzt schon sehr lange. Und es ist so, dass diese Bankensysteme schon sehr lange an den jeweiligen, also die hängen einfach an der EZB, die kriegen am Geldmarkt auch kein Geld mehr. Also das war aber schon, und deswegen wundert es mich, dass es andere immer wundern. Das war schon 2008 so. Das heißt, die kriegen kein Geld mehr von anderen Banken geborgt, sondern nur noch von der EZB? Genau. Okay.
Na, aber es hieß ja gleichzeitig in der Presse...
Lass mal ein, zwei Ausnahmen immer geben, aber weitestgehend sind die alle platt. Weil die sich verhoben haben? Weil sie sich verhoben haben und weil sie sich halt auch mit Staatsanleihen ihres eigenen landes halt vollgepumpt haben. Die dann wiederum halt nun jetzt nicht besonders ausfallsicher sind? Ja, sie sind einer der größten Anleiheninvestoren, also der größte Anleiheninvestor der Welt mit, ich glaube, 1,1 bis 1,2 Billionen Dollar. Hat jetzt so vor zwei, drei Tagen gesagt, Griechenland sechs Monate, Herkat sind die Plattstaatspleite. Herkat heißt, du kriegst als Investor nur einen Teil wieder. Also du kriegst nur noch einen Teil deiner Anleihen wieder ausgezahlt. Von Zinsen gar nicht zu reden. Naja, die sind weg.
Wobei Pimko hat auch angesagt, dass sie den us-schuldenberg, dass sie da jetzt gegenwetten mit ihren Lesben schon. Also das ist schon...
Ja, Pimko muss man dazu sagen, die gehören zur Allianz. Das ist eine Tochter der Allianz. Ach, das ist eine Tochter der Allianz? Und die drehen halt schon ein richtig großes Rad. Die haben ihre US-Staatsanleihen komplett verkauft, wetten jetzt tatsächlich auch gegen US-Staatsanleihen, wobei der Deal bisher noch nicht aufgeht. Also von der Rendite sind die bisher ziemlich weit hinten. Und werden jetzt wohl auch Probleme bekommen, wenn die Amis da doch noch ihr komisches Paket da durchdrehen. Das wäre, glaube ich, schon eher ein Falls als ein Wenn, ne? Also es gab schon mal so eine Situation, und dann haben sie es irgendwie am Tag vorher gelöst. Also das ist so diese typische US-Art. Immer so das heldentum und Obama springt dann in den Ring und rettet alle oder so. Verstehe. Nee, also davon würde ich schon ausgehen, dass da nichts schief läuft, weil sonst können wir eh einen packen und immer was Sinnvolles tun. Momentan entsteht ja so ein bisschen so der Eindruck, als wenn es halt nicht mehr so richtig vorher zu sagen ist, wo es jetzt als erstes knallt. Ob jetzt irgendwie bei den Amis in der Eurozone oder irgendwie, weil die Chinesen sich überhoben haben. Ja, also die Chinesen hängen ja mit den Amis zusammen. Das heißt, wenn es da knallt, knallt es bei beiden. Also die sind so verflochten ineinander. Vielleicht kurz zur Historie. Das heißt ja immer so, die Amis haben die Zinsen viel zu niedrig gehalten. Das Problem war damals, und dadurch sei dann die Finanzkrise entstanden. Das Problem damals war einfach, dass die Chinesen so eine Riesen-Nachfrage nach US-Staatsanleihen generiert haben, dass die Zinsen niedrig bleiben mussten. Also selbst wenn... Also die mussten nicht mehr Zinsen zahlen, weil die Chinesen haben sie eh alles gekauft. Genau, zu quasi jedem Zinssatz. Und da kann so eine Notenbank natürlich die Zinsen anheben, wie sie will. Es ist halt nur ein Leitzins. Der endgültige Zins wird immer noch am Markt gemacht. So und dadurch haben sich die Chinesen halt sehr stark mit den Amis verwoben. Und da bin ich mir eigentlich sehr sicher, wenn das bei den einen Knall knallt, das bei den anderen. Und vielleicht noch als Anekdote am rande, die chinesischen Kommunalkredite, irgendwie auch eine Billion Dollar, werden weitestgehend in außerbilanziellen Vehikeln gefahren. Also so, wie wir das bereits aus der Finanzkrise mit den Banken gelernt haben. Also außerbilanzielle Vehikel heißt irgendwelche eigene Firmen, keimenden, Island Companies, über die niemand so richtig Rechenschaft ablegen muss. So ungefähr, ja. Hintergrund ist der, dass die Kommunen sich da irgendwie nicht verschulden dürfen oder nur bis zum bestimmten Prozentsatz und dann machen sie es halt so.
Also mich interessiert noch, woher man das eigentlich weiß, wer wie viele griechische Staatsanlagen hält. Ist das irgendwie öffentlich ansehbar oder kennst du da jemanden, der jemanden kennt?
Also ich kriege halt ab und zu mal so eine Studien zugeschickt, wo es dann mal drinsteht. So eine richtige offizielle Quelle habe ich auch noch nicht. Also vor allen Dingen kein Link, wo man mal immer wieder drauf schauen kann und der sich dann so selbstständig aktualisiert.
Also die deutsche Presse hat halt ziemlich einvernehmlich geschrieben, dass es da einer der größten Gläubiger Griechenlands, wobei sie halt nicht klar waren, ob das jetzt Staatsanleihen oder irgendwie die Wirtschaft war, sei halt Deutschland. Und das ist halt jetzt...
Das ist aber auch schon merkellich zurückgefahren worden.
Wir haben das alles abgestoßen und wundern uns jetzt, dass es ihm noch nicht besser geht?
Also bei den Banken ging vor einem Jahr noch riesige Summen rum und das sind jetzt irgendwie sonst nur noch höchstens 20 milliarden. Aber wie hat es denn dann gekauft? Irgendwo bleiben das Geld, das hat nicht weggebrannt.
Die Amis haben ja lustigerweise angefangen, da Kohle reinzupumpen.
Die LBBW hat letztens gemeint, dass sie jetzt schon seit längerem ihre Griechenlandanleihen verkauft und jeder andere würde das ja auch tun. Ich kann da hier mal so zum Beispiel an Leute wie mich, die damals beim ersten Rettungspaket dann halt gesagt haben, okay, also zu 60 Prozent nehme ich so ein Ding mal rein, also 60 von 100. Und dann sind die ja auch irgendwie auf fast 90 noch gelaufen und dann kannst du sowas halt auch wieder verkaufen. Und dann sind hier wieder alle anderen am Spekulieren und nehmen das Zeug halt rein.
Ach, du bist einer von diesen fiesen Spekulanten, über den wir immer gemeckert haben, ja?
Äh, ich hab Liquidität gesagt. Super. Und was machst du so beruflich? Äh, Liquidität. Sehr schön. Also, um mal so ein ganz praktisches Beispiel zu geben, wie es jetzt aktuell ausschaut mit diesen Griechenland-Anleihen. Also die, die bis 2020 laufen, wo man eigentlich davon ausgehen kann, dass man nie wieder sein Geld sieht, die kannst du jetzt zu 53 Prozent kaufen, die bis 2015 laufen. Also es werden ja immer keine neuen Grate imitiert, deswegen sind das die längsten. Die bis 2015 laufen, da gab es heute einen Schlusskurs von 48,25 Prozent.
Das ist jetzt mitdeutet.
Also der Hercut ist eigentlich schon eingepreist. Genau, daran siehst du den Hercut. Das heißt, wenn eine Bank jetzt verkauft, dann nimmt sie diese Verluste. Nimmt sie diesen Hercut schon in Kauf sozusagen. Und der Käufer nimmt die dann halt zu diesen Kursen rein. Und was ich an der Stelle überhaupt nicht verstehe, ist, warum die EZB zum Beispiel, die ja auch Griechenland anhand schon gekauft hat für rund 40, 45 milliarden Euro, warum die nicht einfach hergeht und am Markt diesen ganzen Kram zu diesen Kursen aufkauft. Die könnte man umgehend an die Griechen weitergeben, zum Einkaufskurs umtauschen. Und dann hätten die ihren Hercut oder ihren schuldenschnitt, ohne dass es irgendjemandem wehgetan hat. Ohne dass es Hercut heißt. Ja. Und das sind Sachen, da ist so eine amerikanische Notenbank einfach weiter. Weil die halt einfach unkomplizierter agieren, ne? Ja, bei uns hat die die Notenbank irgendwie... Also wir haben das Problem, im November kriegen wir einen neuen Notenbankchef. Und dieser Trichet, der will sie halt da irgendwie noch sein Denkmal waren und sonst noch was und versucht jetzt auch noch tatsächlich ordentlich zu arbeiten. Und das ist ein Keklebend.
Das kann ja nichts werden. Verstehe.
Nicht flexibel genug, ey. Okay. Aber die... Also der Ausgangspunkt von dieser ganzen Geschichte war ja durchaus irgendwie diese, ja, also diese Bubble, die wir dann irgendwie so diversen Papieren hatten. Und... Für Griechenland jetzt? Nee, jetzt überhaupt von dieser ganzen Misere, so seit 2007, 2008, so, dass halt da, ja, Immobilienanleihen in einer Art und Weise bewertet waren, die also nichts mit der Realität zu tun hatten. Na ja, da gab es diese schönen strukturierten Produkte, die, wo irgendwie ein großer Ramsch-Anteil drin war und ein kleiner sowas wie Staatsanleihen oder sowas. Und dann sind halt unsere freunde die Rating-Agenturen.
Du hast ja nicht eine gewisse Ironie, nicht in Beert jetzt, wo die Staatsanleihen auch junk sind.
Ja, das hängt ja zusammen. Also, dem Boben schlagen wir ja gleich sicherlich noch. Und dann sind halt die Rating-Agenturen hergegangen und haben gesagt, ach ja, AAA, alles gut, da sind ja Staatsanleihen drin. Und dann wurde das Zeugs in die Welt vertickt. Na ja, und die Preise dafür waren ja also praktisch nur mit Marketing hochgetrieben. Also Rating-Agenturen und irgendwie ist schon sicher Marketing-Sprech. Ja, also die Bewertungen waren ja im Nachhinein nur nachweislich nicht unbedingt belastbar. Um das mal vorsichtig zu drücken. Sehr diplomatisch von vorn. Ja, man muss ja immer aufpassen im öffentlichen Raum. Also wir haben nur 50.000 Zuhörer, das ist schon okay. Und einer arbeitet bei einer Rating-Agentur. Es ist halt, die Dinger, die Wertungen waren ja Schwachsinn und die haben auch dann die Stand gehalten. Und das Problem war halt, dass diese strukturierten Produkte, da gab es ja fünf, sechs Namen dafür, je nachdem, was sie reingepackt haben, die wurden ja auch tatsächlich dafür hergenommen, dass sich die Banken wieder als Sicherheiten, um ihre Kredite zu bekommen. Das heißt, da wurde schon am bodensatz dann die Bombe gelegt. Und als sie dann geplatzt ist, ja, Geschichte. Aber ich meine, diese Bubbles sind ja eigentlich gibt's ja immer wieder. Also jetzt fahren wir ja gerade in eine Social Media Company Bubble mit irgendwie Facebook und wie sie alle...
Aber nein, das sind grundsolide Firmen.
Ah ja. Also wir haben ja den Herrn Goldbreit hier auf unserer Liste stehen. Der hat mal in einem seiner Bücher geschrieben, gerade so in Bezug auf das 18. und 19. jahrhundert in Amerika, dass das finanzielle Gedächtnis einer Gesellschaft so 20 bis 25 Jahre beträgt. Mittlerweile ist es wahrscheinlich wieder kurzer. Und dann kommt die nächste Bubble und wie das in unserer Zeit so ist, beschleunigen wir ja gerade sehr gerne. Also die Buchempfehlung ist, der heißt Co-operate und das Buch heißt The Short History of Financial Euphoria. Gibt es auch auf Deutsch, wenn wir noch in die Buchempfehlung tun. Aber zähl mal weiter. Ja, zum Thema Bubbles. Du hattest da dieses schöne Beispiel mit irgendwie 30 gesunden jungen Genfer Mädchen. Ich hab das extra nochmal rausgesucht. Geh mal die Geschichte. Eine der ersten Wirtschaftskrisen unserer, zumindest in Europa. Da haben, also ich muss es auch ein bisschen ablesen, deswegen ist es vielleicht etwas stockend. Da haben die Franzosen 30 gesunde junge Genfer Mädchen genommen als Basis für eine Leibrente. Das heißt, man hat Geld an die Franzosen gegeben. Die haben damit ihren Krieg finanziert. Und dann hat man monatlich oder jährlich eine Auszahlung bekommen. Und zwar so. Von den Franzosen. Ja. Und zwar so lange, bis halt diese 30 ja jungen, gesunden Mädchen gestorben sind. Warum wurde diese Anknüpfung gemacht? Früher, also noch weiter davor war es so, dass...
Hey, wenn es schlecht gelaufen wäre, hätten sie die einfach von der Kippe gestoppt.
Pass auf, da gab es Anlegergemeinschaften, die das gemacht haben, und zwar personenbezogen. Dann hat sich bloß irgendwie eingebürgert, dass man, weil es so war, dass man sehr gut weggekommen ist, wenn der andere Hobbs gegangen ist. War ein gefährlicher Job, der... Dann hat man halt so eine Anlegergemeinschaft gegründet, dann haben die sich gegenseitig umgebracht.
Und super!
Deswegen wurden die dann irgendwie später auch verboten. Und das ist so eine Abwandlung davon gewesen, weil die Franzosen einfach irgendwie jeden zweiten Jahr Krieg geführt haben seinerzeit. Und die mussten so irgendwie finanzieren. Also haben sie händeringend nach Einnahmen gesucht. Das mit dem Geld drucken hat zwar geklappt damals noch. So aufgrund des informationsdefizites, weil niemand wusste, wie viel Geld gibt es überhaupt, wie viele schulden hat der Staat. Also das waren damals alles Sachen, die nicht bekannt waren. Im Gegensatz zu heute, also da geht es uns schon besser. Und dann haben sie sich halt so was überlegt. Es ging natürlich dann schief. Naja, dem Mythos nach hat das erheblich dazu beigetragen, dass dann die französische Revolution entstanden ist. Also es gab ja da früher eine Menge solche kreativen Staatsfinanzierungsoptionen. Ich erinnere mich noch an diese eine Geschichte. Ich glaube, es war auch in Frankreich, wo sie denn eine Gesellschaft zur Ausbottung von Silberminen irgendwo in Amerika erfunden haben. Und der Typ, der es getan hat, war irgendwie schon so ein bekannter Schroke, der sich in England nicht mehr blicken lassen durfte, weil er irgendjemand beim Duell erlegt hatte. Und da auch schon irgendwie fette betrügerische Handlungen begangen hat. Aber er kam aus gutem Hause. Er kam aus gutem Hause und dann wurde er vom französischen König beauftragt, irgendwie für Geld zu sorgen. Und hat dann halt Aktien von so einer, ich glaube Minnesota Mining Company war es, glaube ich, verkauft. Und hat dann irgendwie das komplett gefakt, bis hin dazu, dass er dann irgendwann sich irgendwie Kloschars genommen hat und den Schaufeln in die Hand gedrückt hat und die durch Paris hat marschieren lassen. Mit irgendwie davon berichtet wurde, ja, das sind hier die Arbeiter, die dafür die Minnesota Mining Company, die gerade nach Minnesota geschickt werden. Weil wir müssen jetzt, da ist jetzt so viel zu tun in der Minnesota Mining Company, dass wir schon Arbeiter aus Frankreich dahinschiffen müssen, weil sonst irgendwie reicht es nicht mehr mit dem ganzen Silber, was wir da irgendwie nur so aus der erde kratzen. So ging natürlich dann irgendwas total schief und war irgendwie, also das Problem war, dass obendrein noch der halbe französische adel da rein investiert hat. So hat der König den adel verarmt. Das ging natürlich dann irgendwie grandios schief. Solche Geschichten gibt es ja immer wieder, so bis hin zu dieser berühmten Firma. Ich glaube, das war in England, Enterprise of Great Promise, Nobody To Know What It Is. Also eine Firma, die diese Grundhabe gesagt hat, so auf dem Prospekt steht, wir machen irgendwas. Kann man leider nicht sagen, was es ist, aber es wird echt profitabel sein.
Das ist wie heute, oder? Wenn du dir so von gewissen Pre-IPO-Firmen... Genau. Es ist ein Start-up, aber wir können dir nicht sagen, was sie tun, weil das ist geil.
Stealth, genau. stealth-mode. Aber diese Bubbles folgen doch schon sehr regelmäßigen Gesetzmäßigkeiten. Und eigentlich ist... Es gibt da so ein paar Kennzeichen. Eines davon ist, wenn Leute, die sonst vorher nie irgendwie mit diesem Thema zu tun hatten, dir plötzlich anfangen, davon zu erzählen, solltest du... Nee, das ist zu früh. Spiegel. Wenn der Spiegel so ein Titelbild hat, der Euro geht unter, der Dollar verreckt, dann ist das immer so ein Umkehr. Also wenn Leute anfangen, sozusagen dir zu erzählen, dass es irgendwie toll ist, dann weißt du schon, dass jetzt so eine Bubble kommt, aber wir sind noch auf dem aufsteigenden Ast davon. Richtig, ja. Genau. Und wenn es dann halt in der Mainstreampresse ist, dann ist eigentlich die Bubble ziemlich kurz davor zu platzen. Genau. Also Spiegel-Titelbild ist... Man muss den ja nicht mehr kaufen, man kann das Titelbild ja auch so sehen. Eins der besten Indikatoren. Bildzeitung ist auch immer sehr gut. Die Ausnahme ist gerade immer noch Gold, ne? Lustigerweise. Ja, da hat jetzt ja selbst der Commerzbank-Chef sich dazu, oder nicht Chef, aber irgendein Preisleiter hat sich jetzt dazu durchgerungen, mal irgendwie zu sagen, ja, jeder sollte Gold haben. Warum in so einer staatsschuldenkrise jemand Gold haben sollte? Na ja, gut, also Gold hat immerhin den großen Vorteil, dass es irgendwie ein beruhigender Anblick ist, im Gegensatz zu Goldzahlungen. Ja, also es ist halt historisch schon so, dass Gold irgendwo so in jeder Zeit anerkanntes Zahlungsmittel ist. Du brauchst es halt nur irgendwie in so ganz kleinen Dranchen.
Eigentlich willst du doch aber der sein, bei dem mit Gold bezahlt wird, nicht der, der Gold hat, um sich damit Essen zu kaufen.
Da musst du Bauer werden.
Genau. Das ist der Krisenplan, Bauer werden.
Also in der Hyperinflation waren Bauern ja tatsächlich so die Gewinner. Da kennen wir uns ja aus in der Historie hier in Deutschland. Ja gut.
Wir wollten noch erklären, wie Rating-Agenturen funktionieren.
Stimmt. Rating-Agenturen wollten wir noch machen und dann wollten wir uns noch kurz um den Stress-Test kümmern.
Ach und OTC haben wir auch noch nicht erklärt. Wir haben nur den Freiverkehr erklärt.
Wir sind jetzt bei zwei stunden.
Ganz kurz. OTC.
Over the counter. Ja der Name sagt eigentlich schon. Kein richtiger börsenhandel, sondern meist ein Anruf oder ein Fax. Zurück mal rüber. oder wie? Bitte? So. Gib mal oder? Ja also du rufst halt an, weil bei irgendeinem Makler, in irgendeinem mehr oder weniger seriösen Büro und sagst, ich will kaufen und der erledigt das dann für dich.
Ist wie Ebay.
oder auch über die Bank. Das geht auch, wenn man denn am interbankenhandel beispielsweise teilnehmen kann oder da irgendwelche Arrangements hat.
Na wie du den Deal machst, ist ja eigentlich egal. Am ende gehen beide zur Bank und sagen, wir haben diesen Deal gemacht. Und dann wird halt die Aktie übertragen. Das ist so der unregulierte Markt, in dem die ganzen Spam und Penny-Stalks und Junkbund.
Ja also bei Amis ist das so eine ganz harte Geschichte.
Finger weg. Finger weg.
Also halbwegs schlimm ist so dieses OTC-Bulletin-Board und dann gibt es noch was wesentlich krasseres, wo wirklich dann der absolute Schrott drin ist. Das sind diese Pink Cheats. Da wird dann noch mit so, oder wurde früher, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, ob die das machen. Die hatten dann immer so rosa Zettelchen, wo sie dann alles aufgeschrieben hatten und daher kommt der Name. Und das sind de facto halt irgendwelche Schrott-Docs, die halt... Ja, also das ist definitiv... Ich weiß nicht, ob es da irgendeine Ausnahme gibt, aber da kannst du davon ausgehen, nicht unbedingt den Treffer zu finden, der dir dann die Millionen bringt. Weil diese diplomatischen Formulierungen...
Ich muss auch sagen, wir haben es hier mit einem Profi zu tun. So, was hatten wir noch?
Stress-Test.
Damit wollten wir eigentlich anfangen, also machen wir jetzt damit Schluss mit dem Stress-Test. Heute war die Bekanntgabe der Stress-Test-Daten, der europäischen Banken. Was muss man sich unter so einem Stress-Test eigentlich genau vorstellen? Was sind die Banken gesagt?
Ist ja auch ein freudischer Versprecher.
Also in Island habe ich ja den schönen Begriff Bankster gelernt, den ich sehr treffend fand. Ich hab die falschen ausgedacht. Ja, naja, gut aus der Perspektive. Ja, also was ist denn eigentlich so ein Stresstest und wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Ja, wie das funktioniert, wüsste ich auch gerne. Die Daten werden nicht rausgegeben, wie genau die das nun machen. Man kriegt es durch die Streitigkeiten, die dann da rumherum entstehen, immer so ein bisschen mit. Also zum Beispiel, welche Bank war denn das? Das ist die Hela-Bahn, ne? Also die Hessische landesbank war dann der Meinung, dass die Kriterien noch nicht so richtig sind. Da ging es um so eine Sache, dass die, was waren das? Stille Einlagen, ne?
Genau, stille Einlagen.
Der Hela-Bahn wurde immer signalisiert, eure stillen Einlagen, die nehmen wir in den Stresstest mit rein, das ist alles okay.
Als hartes Eigenkapital nehmen wir die rein. Es geht genau um diesen Hebel, den wir vorhin erwähnt haben. Der ändert sich nämlich beim Übergang von Basel II zu Basel III. Der ist jetzt höher und die Bank muss mehr Eigenkapital vorhalten. Und das ist genau das Kernproblem, was dieser Stresstest ja auch prüfen sollte. Und da haben sie jetzt halt gesagt, damit die Banken auch durchkommen, weil bei so einem Stresstest geht es ja nicht um Stresstesten, sondern da sollen alle überlebt werden. Genau, der beunruhigte Markt soll beruhigt werden. Und da ging es halt genau darum, dass die Helaba dann meinte, ne, also wenn die stillen Einlagen nicht eingerechnet werden, dann machen wir nicht mit.
Und die stillen Einlagen? Ja, also da muss man fairerweise sagen, nachdem es ihr die ganze Zeit gesagt wurde, das ist okay und dann mitten im Stresstest irgendwer, wer auch immer auf die idee gekommen ist, zu sagen, nö, jetzt doch nicht. Und dann haben sie halt gesagt, sie nehmen nicht teil. Kann man darüber streiten? Also, sie wären wohl durchgefallen, wenn sie mitgezählt worden wären. Ach so, okay. Das ist jetzt halt so der Knackpunkt. Deswegen haben sie sich da überhaupt so rumgemacht. Also eigentlich sollte der Stresstest ja so eine Art, was passiert, wenn Simulationen sind. Ja, also du machst halt irgendein Worst-Case-Szenario und Worst, Worst, Worst, Worst, Worst-Case-Szenario. Und was passiert, wenn Griechenland 50 Prozent herkann? Was passiert, wenn... Sind dir diese Szenarien denn bekannt? Bei den Versicherungen sind sie bekannt geworden. Bei den Banken habe ich jetzt noch nichts gesehen, was da genau... Und wie sah das aus bei den Versicherungen? Also bei den Versicherungen haben sie tatsächlich so die einzelnen Punkte durchgespielt. Was passiert, wenn der Aktienmarkt abkracht? Was passiert, wenn es...
Und verbrannte erde oder kam da irgendwas raus?
Ja, das war, ich glaube, ich hab die Zahl nicht mehr im Koffer. Das waren irgendwie 13 Versicherungen oder sowas, die da irgendwie ein Problem hatten.
Aber spielt das eine Rolle, wenn der Aktienmarkt wegkracht? Ob die Versicherungen überleben oder nicht?
Doch. Ja, gut, du machst... Also über Aktien dienen ja wiederum als Bewertung. Einmal innerhalb der Bilanz. Das heißt, du hast dann halt so ein Anlageposten und wenn der sinkt, dann machst du Verluste.
Aber du bist ja rückversichert.
Also es gibt ja auch verschiedene bewertungsmethoden. Die einen sagen, wir machen es nach Anschaffungskurs. Die anderen sagen, wir machen, wie halt der Börsenkurs ist.
Nach Anschaffungskurs? Ernsthaft?
Ja, natürlich.
Das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein. Wer macht denn sowas?
Wir zum Beispiel. ordentliche HGB-Bilanzierung mit niederstwert und Anschaffungskurs und so ein Kram. Also es gibt auch in Deutschland noch ordentliche bilanzierungsmethoden, die man anwenden kann. Also aber du hast ja immer so ein bisschen Wahlfreiheit, wie du das machst. gerade je größer du bist. Und sehr viel davon ist dann gerade in dem Bereich Banken und Versicherungen auch irgendwie so ein bisschen Verhandlungssache mit dem Wirtschaftsprüfer. Also das wird gedealt. So bei dem Stresstest wären halt alle möglichen Szenarien, die irgendwie eine Belastung darstellen könnten. Beim Versicherungen waren es dann auch noch so wie irgendwie Stürme, die über irgendwelche Regionen in der Welt herziehen und da x schaden anrichten und so ein Kram. Das heißt, so ähnlich muss man sich denn diese Banken-Szenarien auch vorstellen, dass man sagt, ok, also der Dollar kracht ab oder der Yuan kracht ab? Ja, dann sagt man einfach, die Griechenlandanleihen fallen 20 Prozent, x macht 30 Prozent. So in der Art läuft das. Und das ergibt dann halt irgendeine Belastung und dann guckt man, ob die Banken das überleben anhand der Eigenkapital, harten Eigenkapital-Quota.
Und diese, das macht doch nur depressiv so was. Warum machen die denn sowas überhaupt?
Um Sicherheit in den Markt hineinzubringen. Aber die gute Nachricht wäre doch jetzt, dass wenn dieser Stresstest einigermaßen realistisches Szenarios durchtesten würde, würden die deutschen Banken bei Hessen durchkommen. Gibt es die denn hinterher noch? Der Vorstand kriegt noch Bonus.
Das kann sich wahrscheinlich noch mit dem goldenen endedruck in die Alpen verabschieden.
Diese Boni sind ja auch teilweise schon im Gehalt mit fest verankert. Als feste Zahlung irgendwie. Das hat dann auch wieder steuerliche gründe. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sehe, so eine HSH Nordbank hat 5,5 Prozent Eigenkapital. Da würde ich sagen, die ist mal ziemlich knapp dadurch gekommen. Generell ist es bei den Stresstests so, der erste, den wir letztes Jahr gemacht haben, der ist einfach schwach gewesen. Das war, da ist es dann mal nach außen gedrungen, wie genau die das gemacht haben und das war, vergiss es einfach. Du konntest es nicht ernst nehmen. Deswegen gab es jetzt noch eins. Also waren keine besonders krisenartigen Szenarien, sondern mehr so ein bisschen...
Kommt ihr da auch alle durch?
Da habe ich jetzt die Griechenland 20 Prozent hergenommen, aus so diesen ersten Stresste. So in der Art lief das ab und das ist ja völliger Blödsinn. Vor allem, wenn ich mir hier die Kurse da anschaue von den Griechenland-Anleihen. Jetzt soll es etwas schärfer gewesen sein.
Aber nichts Genaues weiß man nicht.
Also ich habe keine Details, wie scharf genau. Sie haben sich aber sehr gestritten und es hieß dann immer so, ja, so richtig scharf ist das aber auch nicht. Aber wie soll denn sowas vertrauen im Finanzmarkt? Überhaupt nicht. Also, den hätten sie sich auch sparen können. Dann wieder machen sie es halt richtig gescheit. So im Sinne von Herrkat 50 Prozent bei Griechenland. Mal gucken, ob die Bank überlebt. Portugal 50 Prozent. Mal gucken, was da rauskommt. Weil so 50 bis 60 Prozent ist ein sinnvoller Herrkat. Das Argument dagegen war ja, dass sie gesagt haben, dass dadurch zu viele Informationen darüber offeriert würden, wie Spekulanten gegen die spezifischen Banken wetten können. Das war immer das Argument, was irgendwie die Barfin oder wer auch immer diesen Stress macht. Allein die Aussage gibt mir schon wieder so viel Information, wie ich dagegen wetten kann, dass ich mir auch gleich sagen können. Ist das so? Ja, also du kannst ja aus diesen ganzen Aussagen, kannst du ja sehr viel rausziehen. Dann, man kann ja eine Bilanz lesen, also diese Risikoberichte und diesen ganzen Kram. Man kann ja auch auf eine Hauptversammlung gehen und mal ganz genau nachfragen, wie hoch sind denn eure Engagements? Und dann haben die halt so auch so ein recht großes Auskunftsrecht, die Aktionäre. Und das heißt also jeder, der irgendwie professionell in diesem Markt agiert und sich mit diesen Sachen beschäftigt, der wird schon diese Sachen auch erfahren. Okay, also der weiß dann halt im Zweifel auch, wo die Risiken bei den Banken sind. Genau. Das heißt also diese Aussage, dass sie es uns nicht sagen wollen, ist eigentlich Bullshit? Ja. Okay. Das ist doch schon mal. Und dann gibt es ja noch so diese hintergründigen Informationen, die man halt über Gerüchte und generelles Netzwerken und was weiß ich noch alles erfährt.
Also wir sind ganz oahm.
Also es ist halt einfach so, dass die meisten Sachen, auch damals hatten wir auch in der Finanzkrise gesehen, es war trotz sehr vieler Gerüchte, wer pleite geht, war immer ganz klar, wer wirklich pleite geht. Also Lehman und das HRE und diesen ganzen, das war immer unbestritten. Es ging dann immer nur noch darum, schaffen die anderen es auch und wer ist da noch wackelig? Okay, verstehe. Ja gut, dann machen wir hier mal Schluss. Wie immer, run for the hills.
Moment, eine Sache noch. Lustigerweise die Bank mit dem höchsten Eigenkapitalanteil ist die landesbank Berlin. Ich dachte so, was? Die mit dem Bankenskandal? Sollten die nochmal was richtig gemacht haben? Überraschend.
Und die HRE-Gruppe?
Die sind auf Platz zwei.
Wahrscheinlich haben die noch 10,0. Wahrscheinlich genug bundeskode drinne.
Ja, da würde ich vermuten, dass sie da Sachen angerechnet gekriegt haben.
Das ist diese Abspaltung, die das saubere Geschäft macht, was noch rettbar ist. Ach so, und der Rest ist sowieso schon in der Bad Bank. Ja, okay. Ja gut, viel über Geld geredet, falls ihr noch ein bisschen Geld überhaupt. Unser Flatter-Button ist da auf der Webseite. Wir werden dann hauptsächlich gleich mal gucken, was wir mit dem Geld machen. jedenfalls nicht in Bad-Banks anlegen. Ansonsten wieder vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und dann... Ach so, nicht vergessen, wir sehen uns auf dem Camp, falls wir es nicht noch schaffen, vorher noch eine Folge zu machen. CCC Camp ist demnächst, noch gibt es Tickets. Schnell klicken, eventsccc.de gibt es die Links. Und dann ansonsten bis zum nächsten Mal. Und vielen Dank an unseren Gast, den MH.
Auf wiedersehen.